two hey guys I'm here it's a solemn
Monday
actually um nobody died but it feels
like
it yeah today is uh
Monday the day after the streamy
[Music]
awards
and I literally predicted that of
this despite all you guys and all you
guys peer pressuring me into going hold
on a minute go ahead try to defend
yourself I said J shete was going to win
repeatedly dude it wasn't just he that
he won it was the commercial break slj
shete winning okay I mean that part was
a little
that was the ultimate disrespect you
broke my heart I frankly didn't expect
it I didn't think that they would stoop
that low
no you
know listen last year it was the
commercial break and lost to J shett yep
or no last year was uh caller D caller
daddy caller daddy year before was J
shett and the
year and I said I'm not why would I go
to this award show they don't even
announce my
category for whatever reason cuz like
some of these categories no offense to
the to the nominees there I'm not saying
they're not deserving but they're
reading off that like I don't
understand why podcast doesn't get any
respect loser seems to be a big category
yeah we should be in show though Olivia
you're right about that yes I was was
saying next year I think we should
submit for show and I think that that
would that would maybe change things no
cuz then we have to be good mythical
morning and they win every year maybe
maybe it wouldn't change things loser
they had link right in the front row and
he they didn't win though yeah I
know but like we're not going to beat
them I feel like we've been in podcast
for so long now that we just got to
stick it out I feel like we have the
best chance in podcast no it's yeah I'm
not I'm not changing I'm not changing
for them like relationship with them is
permanently and forever
severed um don't sacrifice your
integrity the where's the category
winners
here by the way we don't have any
sponsors today they saw that I was a
loser yeah that we lost to J
shett and everybody canceled their ads
for today yeah they gave me a ring this
morning and they were they were
apologetic but they were firm you're
going to go to bed and you're still
going to be a loser we don't
work with losers yeah so I guess now's a
good time to say hey you can become a
member and you guys owe me that after
this debacle get a uh exclusive members
stream on Tuesdays with just me without
any of these
clowns they just Spam to me on Whatsapp
trying to save my
life so there they have a minor uh role
to play sporting role
yeah also you get my Social Security
number my phone number my uh driver's
license and my birth certificate mhm
routing number account
number security codes DNA
sequence right genetic my whole
genome all of
it access to
Discord whatever you don't want to
subscribe to a loser either put your
clothes on I ain't ready for
that I'm on a Discord so like again so
this this is what is annoying okay last
year they announced it during the
commercial
break and we lost whatever it's it's one
thing to lose but it's another to do it
during the commercial break so I've been
saying why would I I have no reason to
go there like last year Ian was there
with Bizarro Ethan M Ian yeah and they
didn't even know that the category was
done and even at the table a lot of a
lot of you guys were confused like I was
sitting next to
Sam and you completely missed it right
that
was hold on sorry I was muted uh yeah I
was like that was it I didn't even
realize that I thought they were talking
about like past winners or something
literally it was so disrespectful why
even have the categories why invite me
you were like they announced us and I
was like did we win I literally was like
okay and and then it was all over so
quickly wow and so I said to the
streames listen I'm not coming because
you don't even announce our category
like why would I come like it's just you
know whatever I don't care and they said
to us do not
come I wish they said that to us what
they said to us is well the reason the
podcast category didn't get announced is
because all the nominees weren't there
right and I said and then I told you
guys that and I guess we're like okay I
guess that makes sense
mhm so we said okay we're going to go to
this award show and you and I
knew it I said they're going to J shed's
going to beat me and it's going to be
during a commercial break and everybody
said no this year's going to be
different this year's going to be
different I mean they basically told us
that they wouldn't do
that and so we get
there we have our own table behind fake
Charlies literally behind last year last
year they put eth fake Ethan in a in a
more Cozier higher status uh seating
arrangement than real Ethan behind
behind you know and they put it at the
end too I watch there Faithfully
gracefully cheering on all the winners
yay yay behind waiting patiently
nervously as I went through the speech
in my
mind as I uh sat there with great
anticipation we had come towards the
back 20% of the show and I said yo we
haven't been yada yed
yet because there were two yada Yas
before us where they just announced
losers during the commercial break and I
was like maybe it's not happening then
all of a sudden after some dumb
try Guy Christmas
and by the way not exactly like
entertaining okay streamy it's not and
by the way all my fans you guys were
watching they didn't need to be wasting
their Sunday night watching that go
that
you know what I
me and by the way when you stiffed us
your live views went down by
12,000 suck that
he up literally such a
joke of a of a
organization they were very nice I had a
lovely
time I'm not done
Dan I'm I'm done and
so let's see right after there was a
fake Among Us
bit what year is it a Among Us can we
move on
please it's 2023 it's not the year of
among us anymore why the are we
doing this what year is it how about
that Spider-Man Elsa bit too Spider-Man
Elsa yeah what that had to have been
homage to you I'm sorry no I mean it was
a big category it back then it was big
thing they could just say my name as a
winner if they wanted to do an homage
there's an
homage what's your
name it's Ethan
kleene his name is Ethan kleene if you
didn't
know and so I wait there and right after
Spider-Man's Frozen Elsa Among Us bit to
a group to a a room full of
adults who have better to do on a
Sunday
night are you crazy then sit there and
pretend to be
entertained I have kids I have dogs I
have a dog who's not well I'm not even
kidding every moment I get to spend with
him is a blessing and you took that away
from
me you broke my heart you think I
wouldn't be I I I value my free time and
I feel that they tricked me into coming
they tricked our audience
watching and
so you
know right after
uh what the dumb bits did they
do they were all bad Oh I thought Matt
Pat's bits were hilarious oh stop it I
had such a good time that's my why
you even doing this Dan don't like why
you don't have to be contrary right now
okay
you walked out with
me I wasn't going to sit there by myself
no no no you walked out with me stop
that was the last one out J shett is not
going to hire you bro get over it you're
not J shett material not even
close so I ate a little fruit um so
right after that they go okay we'll be
right
back go to a commercial they just roll
some on the screen and then
everybody's like I'm not going to pay
attention I'm going to go to the
bathroom
whatever and and uh for podcast J shete
all
[Music]
right you
know I'm just saying I have better
things to
do you know people on the red carpet
they're asking
me oh what do you think about Malibu
Barbie like I'm about to say that
baby what did they expect like I don't
know it's a dumbass question so dumb
babby they go what do you think about
this child this innocent beautiful child
should it
exist can you that's so crazy could you
go back in time and uh you know of
course I love I love kids there's some
funny red carpet
I did all that stuff for them I did
all for you I did all for you guys thank
you and it's feels good to be right I
had a lot of fun I'm really happy we
went I had a blast yeah honly it was a
great time hanging out with you all I
hope we go again we're not going again
you can go without me I'm I I can't
believe you guys are even wanting to to
support this organization actually
you're right I'm out it was more just
the hangout session with all you guys
that was we can hang out anytime
anywhere dude I said that to you guys
last time
and have open bar complimentary wine
bottles on the table delicious little
treats star studed night on YouTube's
sexiest night okay that's what I'm
saying it was literally YouTube sexiest
night it was YouTube sexiest night we
had to be there yeah all right well I
hope you cherish the memory cuz it's
never happening again I will
I've always I've always sided with you
Ean the night wased always support you
thank you Zach it was a joke the night
was a joke how good was the show d
man uh Matt Pat's hosting was on point I
thought he had a great energy and a
Charisma he clearly rehearsed it down
pat he had every beat blocked out in his
head and I I was blown away by the
production I'm not even on Matt
Pat he did fine I admire him that
frankly I told Ela when I was saw Matt
Pat I don't think there's been a host of
the streames which is such a
dysfunctional show who pays
for that nobody even watches that
Bro their live stream had like 30,000
live viewers half of them was was family
it got up a lot higher than that I think
no it did not bro maybe 36 Peak Max it
didn't bro I swear to and it was
live on Matt Pat's Channel and even now
I bet it doesn't have a million views
watch I think it might it had like
800,000 when I looked this morning so by
it might but legit like who's paying for
this show they spent a lot of
money big is how you pay it back how
would they paying me back that's a good
question they can't pay me
back the since when is autoplay
trailers a thing for a while um 840 bro
it doesn't even have a million views
Jesus that's embarrassing like I'm sorry
this is supposed to be like YouTube's
biggest award show even the Academy
Awards which is like down in the dumps
gets a few million
live it's actually embarrassing like you
have all the biggest influencers these
people so the live stream had the almost
880,000 liers no it did not everyone in
the chat is saying so on which where on
on mad or somewhere
else I saw 80k
75k it was at like this 89 at some
point I didn't see
that Bots dude well okay whatever the
the fact of the matter is that's still
not that impressive like you have all
the biggest influencers in the world
these people by themselves each
individually pull that much or more and
somehow when you put them all in a room
in the streamy package nobody wants to
watch
it what the does that say about the
streames like all all the biggest a lot
of big twitch streamers was there iow
speed was there Kai was there xqc xqc
was there those guys
combined you know like okay so someone
said 36 on YouTube I was watching on
YouTube it was also I believe streaming
on two um two uh channels I think Matt
Pat had it and then there was a streamy
official people are saying they agree
they only saw 40K on okay who cares it
wasn't that good
anyway you know what I mean who cares
what and so
somehow you take all the popular
streamers in the world live viewers
dream was there with a mask bro we get
it we know what you look like why would
you even do thaton like you're a grown
ass man you can't put the mask back on
he was switching it up all night too you
can't put the have to pick let's go you
can't put the turds back in your butt
buddy
he finally took off the mask let's go
dream that was
weird you know what I
mean yeah and all and then people anyone
with any dignity at all no no uh no
disrespect to everybody there but anyone
with self-respect and dignity did not go
to that show and half the winners didn't
go to that show including the
first winner they're like let's go
streamy the first winner is oh they're
not here no they're not
there a joke
man it's a
joke H didn't go he's smart anything was
better than that Mr Beast didn't go Mr
Beast has never gone he won creator of
the Year 4 years in a row and he has
never gone he didn't even send them a
personalized video this year because he
he knows that it's
dumb I think this is this is the uh nail
in the coffin of of the streamings this
organization is absolutely done
and I'll tell you what else next time
that the streamings go live we are going
to be running counterprogramming finally
we are going to go live at the same time
with the stream with the steamies that's
awesome yeah it's like our own version
of guess what we'll probably have nearly
as many maybe more yeah for
sure what
Dan why are you rolling your
eyes why cuz well first of all we're
probably not going to do that I want to
okay well we do the steamies at a
totally different time of the year well
we're moving
it okay
well it nevered sure okay let's move got
it third annual fourth
annual and we're going to make it a
Monster Bash we should Rend out
a like a u big ass Studio have a live
audience yep we should red
carpet is there a venue across the
street from them we can
use just have big ass bright
spotlights suck all the energy from that
place man well go to the uh opposing
hotel to where it was I believe there's
a hotel down the street that's the one
yeah just stream on
Rumble stream on
Rumble
so uh Honestly though such a joke man
I'm just pissed because they misled us
they intentionally misled us man wasted
my time somebody said it's going
to take six months for ELA to get Ethan
out of the house yeah more like six
years here we have a ton of clips and
stuff of us at the show
um here's the moment we lost watch
they're going to come claim us too I bet
scumbags this is how they get their
revenue from claiming our podcast we pay
for this
show throw like a blast pack over the
wall um that's a way off podcast on
purpose with Jay Shetty I don't think we
celebrate the transitions enough in life
and life is made up of transition nobody
cares dude that's not even interesting
to say what does that even mean yeah you
you know what I mean transition these
nuts in your
mouth
science and engineering I did a
thing and then shoved in the metal pin
and it's done which it's unterrified and
really not I I genuinely think like it's
just rude to all these people if any of
these people come and you yada yada them
during a commercial break it's just rude
don't have the
category
oh yeah I wanted to read you all the
winners I saw kaison out on the stage
and I got freaked out I thought I was
about to get trampled in a
riot I had to I had
to look around the corners of the room
make sure his fans were weren't nearby
Crea of the Year Addison Ray wait is
this really this
year's Addison Ray what has she done oh
my God are you kidding everything
okay I'm glad a lost ugly I have
her Barbie sitting with me at all times
that's that's last year's right there
the 12th this is last year's yeah yeah
so y all you want to you guys wanted to
send me the uh yep I just the correct
one thank
[Music]
you all right here it is it's like the
same people what's ironic it's the same
people crat of the year here Mr Beast
aack glad he lost J Shetty lost at least
I thought he was going to do a full
sweep the
but Mr Beast won four years in a
row and he's never gone it's
awesome show of the Year friend of the
show actually we love her challenge
accepted Michelle care is that how you
say
it she's awesome she was really actually
she she came up and said she's a fan of
the show and all kinds of nice stuff we
Lov her for that she she was awesome in
careator Clash yeah fighter yeah she won
man she had she had grit boy I remember
her fight was one of the best ones
really
good you know what's tripped me out Sam
and
Colby these are the guys that did the
kidnapping and murdering my best friend
prank with Sam Pepper back in the day
really they're back last from the past
Sam and Colby that's awesome who's
Sam uh yeah stream of the Year Kai sonat
thank you by the way literally
everybody's
nominated throw my name in in the
show of the year you know what I
mean it where am I in this list
feel like we're so much more than just a
podcast I do feel that we would fit in
the show category but without a it
has podcast in the title I guess so
whatever
yeah
what are you eating up I nectarine ooh
nice very nice just got a fruit up
before I get all energized and
angry RW
up all right so kais at streamer of the
year that's fine yeah deserve I suppose
International I think uh great short
form I never heard of any of these
people not not even to be rude but a lot
of the categories and I'm not saying
they're not deserving I just think I
didn't know who they were there's just a
whole world on Tik Tok now of these
massive influencers and there's just too
many of them like literally who I don't
know any of these people do you guys no
I don't the winner is Chris Olen let's
check him
out
oh this guy this guy swept dude I saw
him on stage constantly let's watch one
of
his that's pretty impressive isn't it
yeah yeah that's terrifying that seems
like really dangerous you could break
your ankle so easily
dude those are pretty durable I got to
say those look sturdy yeah those ones
are less
scary this a Prett high level content to
be honest yeah I mean he deserved it
clearly I'm happy with the dub
there I couldn't do
that breakout Creator Dylan
Mulaney that I'm that I'm fine with you
know breakout
streamer are we get two in the weeds
with breakout streamer it's you already
did Breakout Creator like why the
do we need a breakout streamer well I
think they like realized that the
streaming communities are so active to
watch this kind of things not active not
that active watching that not but
but like the cue Cinderella streamy
Awards was like massive success had way
more viewers than uh the Cutie
Cinderella she did a streamy she did
like a stream Awards like stream right
right she did her own one and that I
think they had more views than this
actually oh definitely and probably on
like literally a 50th of the budget
they're probably trying to piggyback on
that a little bit maybe we'll win that
one next but why not yeah why not the
podcast category it I do feel like
that's a main category breakout streamer
we didn't need this no offense you
already have breakout Creator does a can
a streamer not be a Creator like why
have this category dumb asses
morons collaboration Mr Beast and the
Rock literally just them talking for
five minutes maybe not even that a
minute on the red
carpet how's that a collaboration that's
not that's that's not a
collaboration I mean yeah it's very
weird I I don't know it got a lot of
likes I guess but dude a collaboration
is when two people come together plan
content and execute it right look this
just makes me lose faith in
humanity right I just I swear to God I
hate to get all like goth playy
on here but mhm I'm just just I'm it's
gone brother it's why should we even go
move on I mean there's what what you
know I'm with you Zach it's like this is
like a PR Meetup you know this
is not like oh let's make a cool video
it's what 30 second video I bet they
tried to invite the rock they definitely
losers they're like Rock come
out to the streames it it's climate
change and this are making me lose my my
faith in humanity I feel you bro collab
of the year a 50c tick
talk to rock paper scissors if you beat
me I'll donate $100,000 to charity
whichever one you want wow you ready
nice CL of the Year
scissors yo he didn't go rock he didn't
go rock come on
man yo this is fire collab yo this
collab is off the rails right now bro he
is the rock no he's the rock so I
expected him to go rock but he didn't go
rock he should have just put his head in
his own hands his whole being is Rock he
says I play this
win I will match that and donate
$100,000 to any charity you want really
wow here we
go yo this collab is sick you ready hold
on a second hold on a second I'm ready I
got it I'm
excited I got it too okay
[Music]
yes oh my God you guys this
collaboration is crazy right
now if it makes you feel better I'll
still donate 100 as well a now no
disrespect to Jimmy because this is a
good video but it's not a collaboration
it's stupid what are you do are
you actually trying to honor creators
like what is the point of this award
ceremony clearly not to be a genuine
good faith
representation Jared Leto y'all really
thought Jared Leto was going to come to
this joke of an
event so
thoughtful
hey what's up with your cat I don't care
bro why don't we make Mr bees win all
the categories they basically that's it
he does good short
form breakout stream long long form
short you know Beast reacts did Beast
reacts is my breakout creator of the
year yeah and streamer
mhm okay so collaboration of the Year
creator for social good F good you know
what I mean invisible people shout out
yeah that that that was very nice when
uh he won that that was sweet he was
yeah we we like him yeah create our
product instead of podcast create our
product instead of
podcast just a Prime speaking of
I have a prime in the fridge that I'm
going to grab is that the one yeah it's
the
one what it has Co on it no no it
doesn't I put more Co on it this
morning crossover you already did celebr
you already did collaboration what the
is a
crossover Jonas Brothers what does that
even mean like they didn't come by the
way you think the Jonas brothers are
coming to the
streames give me a break dude do not
come I I'm humiliated that I even
went this is a stain on my otherwise
perfect reputation
it's a skid mark it on the underwear of
society thank you Zach preach
that has Teddy fresh ever been nominated
uh somebody asked in chat no no never
that's
okay nope I mean there's a lot of good
products out there like Feast
tables and
Prime
mhm crossover I don't even know what
that means you already had a club
category what's the
difference no
podcast nope how is crossover better
first I don't even know what first
person is the guy who made the the video
announcing it was even joking about I
don't even know what the this means
cuz my videos are in third person yeah
that is
true I don't know what first person
means this isn't my first is it like
vlogger why did it do make any sense I'm
doing a first person right now how about
this how about a Street podcast first
person I don't know well who that first
person's literally impossible that'd be
like this that' be like the show was
like this the name makes no
sense first person do you know what that
means
morons that's like when you're inside
their brain
right
let me Google this the term first
person refers to speakers I or
me and if when you're talking about
literary okay first person narration the
narrator is a person in the story
telling the story from their own point
of view okay I guess it's
fine it's
me I are we all right I shouldn't have
looked it up yeah still first person
doesn't make any sense just say Vlog
just say vlogger you know what I mean
off stupid ass just chatting what does
that mean we already had streamer of the
year now you want to do one for just
chatting that literally means I'm doing
nothing right now best person at doing
nothing I'm just chatting
just literally what the is just
chatting how they have they have let's
see streamer of the Year breakout
streamer just chatting variety streamer
what does that
mean oh it's so Shameless they're just
trying to pigy back of the like twitch
Community but I feel like they had all
these categories last year too they did
okay well that Cas I think so I don't
think it's that different I think
so like cuz I know what it means they
couldn't fit in the podcast category in
this they had to yada yada it are you
kidding me and by the way the
winner was there Jay shett was there he
was you know what I mean that man
doesn't miss an event looking fabulous
he doesn't miss an event yeah he was
taking pictures with the CEO he was
throwing those beautiful eyes everywhere
y sure was he look so great I we said hi
he was nice so nice I told him he had
beautiful eyes he was super super
grateful for that he d me after really
well he said to me we finally meet yes
he
did I'm sure he was aware of all of your
talking and then he he mess I I
wasn't following him on Instagram he
cold dm'd me that's awesome and he said
now now I do you know he said so good to
finally meet you
a dude you know he's just trying to put
himself in a position where if I
continue to be mean to him then I'm an
he doesn't care about me do you
think he sent that message I felt like
it's just like a publicist no he def
sent it so personal well well to be fair
love might be on to something because
his page is like pure posting
corporate weird stuff I would tell him
to go himself I do think it was him
though I I feel like someone gave him a
list at the end of the day it's like
these people you interacted with he said
he said thank you I said hey dude
congrats on the win he said thank you
mate you deserve it it that's
that's that ain't him well when we I
have a video of us meeting but I was
like bro you deserve it I got no shot
bro it's all you and then he's like no
you so should tell him to go
himself hey that's our guy Mr shed he's
nice of course he's nice he loved you I
I'll say it I'll say it watching that
was so nice you guys were like hey man
hey man he said he was very he was he
was very endeared it seemed
that's his whole stick though that's
what he's good at yeah it's a phony
thing man you know well then I would
like to adopt those skills you better
then do then you better watch on purpose
on purpose how to manipulate
people J
shett he's high roading you Ethan
exactly Ben he's high roading me which
pisses me the
off you know what I mean hell no you he
ain't High roading
me you can't High Road me cuz I
literally live on the low road bro are
you high right now
no just chatting variety streamer vtuber
I don't want to piss off the vtu
community I I think it's a pretty
popular category I
just I just don't it's not part of my
world and I think the podcast is pretty
I mean here's the winner I'm just
curious what's their like
engagement oh cool they haven't uploaded
in one video in 6 months oh no they
stream
vtuber why no respect for podcasts I
genuinely don't understand it Music
Awards whatever
podcast
l hell scripted series unscripted
series animated go back to scripted
Series yeah oh the Bryce thing won that
uh the um somebody who made that came up
to me and Ally and uh introduced himself
and he said was a huge fan of the
podcast oh we love him then
congratulations to
Bry love for him Brandon Rogers where
I'm a huge fan I always have been
I had a great speech plan I was going to
go up there and dedicate the whole
thing to J
shett I was going to say honestly I wish
I could say I was happy to be here but
honestly I'm just sad that Jay shett
didn't win and I was going to have him
stand up and I was like Jay where
are you stand up everyone give him a
round of applause that would been
awesome I was so tuned in and you know
what's the saddest part I thought we
might win wait I mean I and I felt it I
felt it cuz cuz I was like why would
they bring bring us here just to
commercial shete us it's so it's so
disrespectful like we we can't even get
our own you know our own section it has
to be during a commercial mhm right I
kept going back and forth whether or not
we're going to win when we got there our
table was like in the middle of the
whole event but then people farther back
than us were winning right dude Mich was
behind us and I show speed was right
next to us too and he won the table
placement doesn't matter for if you're
going to win or not so I kept going I
thought when got there no we're losing
but then after the other winners won
Michaela by the way sweetheart Legend
she was so nice so
sweet that was she she say she's a big
fan she watches all the time so to
Michaela if you are watching shouts I
got to Meetup bag makeup bag got to meet
Ethan Klein who I'm a huge fan of I love
the H3 podcast when did she say that on
the Reddit I don't know
make a bag she was really
nice other people I ran into I ran into
xqc and it was nice I think we both are
the type of people that like we don't go
into the world like angry when we meet
people so we connected a little bit it
was it was fine that's nice dude when I
was with him chatting with
him some old lady walked by and she was
like losing her mind she's like oh my
God just he didn't know her she goes oh
my
God look at you you're
stunning she wouldn't leave like he she
was trying to tap that
H oh interesting I'm just
[Laughter]
saying say was her name Olivia who he
was wearing like a blinged out like uh
he was fashionable yeah he looked fresh
he was wearing a uh diamond bracelet I
asked him if it was real and how much it
cost oh oh here's another thing he
swears that he knew that I lived that
his watch wasn't more expensive than my
house he swears that that was the joke
but I kept saying well what was the joke
then he says I've been watching you
forever I know that my watch isn't isn't
he said
that I've been watching you forever
obviously I know my watch expens maybe
he said I watched you since I was a kid
a that's
sweet but I don't understand the joke
then me neither but it was still I mean
still was a nice uh viral moment
he mhm but okay she was nice he was
nice who else did we run it to
Manny what's the whole name Manny mua
super nice guy MH also fan of the show
was very sweet he said he's a foot
soldier T I ran
into she says she's like I'm so sorry
about the James Charles thing I'll call
in and disavow him whoa really well
she's like it was a huge mistake I
shouldn't have done that oh oh
interesting oh well I was like I was a
little bit Sor over that well cuz I was
like why would you go be back and be
friends with him I don't understand and
um she's like I don't know why I did it
I regret it and I don't understand why I
did it I'll call in and disavow I love
that I love her that's so awesome I like
T that's like so much more than anyone
else in his circles ever done that's
true even people who used to associate
with him hasn't really said anything
about it they just silently moved away I
like that a lot you got some Chick-fil-A
there yeah what else you got well I got
did you get the new sandwich what
happened wait you guys all got
Chick-fil-A well I just got some fries
since we were doing a Chick-fil-A order
for the show oh did that happened
already it's here it just okay oh yeah
dude out the
Chick-fil-A cheers my dude I guess
there's a new cheers there's a new
sandwich thank you so I'm I'm HonorBound
to try
it but I'm still talking about the
streaming
um who else do we run
into Davis Johnson was sitting at the uh
table next to us it's cool to connect
with him good guy he's a big fan
apparently like his cont
too what is
this it might be the caramel Shake it's
the new like caramel crumble something
something you'll trying to kill
me um yeah honestly it wasn't as awkward
as I thought it would would be in terms
of like seeing
people because
frankly all those people have more
self-respect than me and didn't go to
that dumb
event the Paul Brothers oh the people
that it actually would have been awkward
to run into yeah well xqc is a pretty
awkward one you guys just had a giant
fight like two weeks ago and that was
fine so I think
xqc is more down to earth than the Paul
Brothers also they this weird thing on
Twitch where like mhm like you were
telling me and it's true they like beef
all the time and there's only like five
popular streamers so they have to be
friends yeah no they they they forget
in one one week everyone's beefing
the next week everyone's chilling true
yeah oh we also met um is show speed's
Dad right was sitting at the table next
to us he was really nice guy that was
pretty funny yeah um there's there's
albums of pictures of a lot of this we
should just go through those yeah we're
going to go through it in a second here
so I don't know man Beauty Michaela
congratulations Queen comedy I do comedy
I make people laugh I try to commentary
I do commentary what do you think I'm
doing right now yeah I
morons guess who wasn't there crit
critical why would he
be
dance fashion style food game
gamer
gamer it's
2023 dream went up there with a
mask on like we all don't know what he
looks like also doesn't he just play
Minecraft he doesn't even he cheats on
Minecraft yeah he a cheeter Bro
him they did that one on stage
gamer where were where were uh dreams
fans in the audience didn't see
them past their bedtime apparently the
live chat was all family that's true
cam
um kids and
family yeah you mean parents who are
exploiting their kids let's bring up the
criminals give them an
award learning and education lifestyle
news H Hassan won that he beat Philip
def Franco which is good
so um by the way neither of them there
Phil lives in La he didn't go that
right Hassan
too I just want to um point out though
that Hassan said on leftovers last week
that being a host of leftovers with you
means that if we won best podcast it
technically means that he won well
leftovers is also kind of a news show
and he won best news so in a way you won
best news Ethan well to be fair I told
him you're absolutely not coming on
stage with us
so now we regret that I don't know if I
we could have gone up and accepted his
reward on his uh on his behalf that
would have been
funny deal with this chick-fil sauce it
looks like baby the colors are not
right it's yummy um science and
engineering okay they yada yed that
one
technology brownley he wasn't there why
would he be fortnite they did the edit
now no disrespect to the editors
because I myself as an editor in my the
the majority of my career I was editing
my own videos I've always I have mad
respect for editors good editors is a is
a skill an art form that being
said podcast wasn't announced and editor
was
oh that's weird yeah or at least they
got like they gave them like a little
one where they went to their
table and gave them the award and gave
them the full speech and then I was
thinking why not just do it normally why
do you need to like make them feel
lesser than it literally took as much
time yeah editing got screen time I
didn't even get to see J shed's
beautiful piercing eyes giv me a gaze of
a miracle although he no he did
present yeah he
presented
writing I met one of Zach Kings guys he
nice guy he said Zach watches the show
love you Zach agency of the Year shut up
dude agency of the year and then brand
engagement
oh insta 360 I don't know what the
that is
it's just it's just a link to Tik
Tok brand engagement instant 360 just a
link to Tik
Tok I think it's that hashtag the
hashtag is what
won no drone no problem yeah cuz it says
that on the if you go back to the
streamy winner list viral marketing
campaign this is dumb bro shame
on you guys for even having this
category Jersey miks are we giving out a
to Jersey miks at the stream
e sub for Subs team solo mid and to
finally I want to welcome Jersey Mike it
on stage here for the best sandwich
collaboration Jersey Michael was Rob
dude brand of the Year Barbie
wow congratulations to Barbie you are
brand of the year I really thought Prime
video had it this year I really thought
Prime video had it but Barbie she's too
much of a juggernaut I was personally
rooting for Chipotle Mexican Grill
that's a long shot they were Underdog
for sure give I feel like they've people
dis Terry they've been nominated for
like the last like 13 years like I feel
like they're always in that category
Chipotle yeah they're like the H3
podcast of brand of the Year
babby you deserved it Chipotle no you
didn't your food sucks I haven't eat
there in like a year cuz it makes me
sick branded series shut up branded
video what all the brand did get
a life influencer campaign social impact
my God what the so this a joke dude
it's and I don't again I don't know
who's paying for it I mean I know they
have sponsors YouTube must be
subsidizing the out of that cuz the
money the money side of that makes no
sense to me yeah I think so too it's not
just
YouTube I'm saying YouTube must be
subsidizing a large part of it
I guess perhaps so much of it is uh so
much of it is uh twitch and Tik Tok
people though and the twitch CEO was
there so the twitch CEO was there
actually so the platforms are
subsidizing it yeah maybe that's why
there's a billion streamer we got to
talk about the only other guy in the uh
audience that was more pissed than us
and that was the twitch CEO yeah he got
up they made a twitch joke about how
much they've been up this past
year and he got up and took like an
angry laugh his face was red in the face
yeah he was like walking around he was
pissed I don't know what happened I
actually have a I have a closeup of him
when he really let's let's go through
all the media we've
got let's
[Music]
see the moment we lost here's a video of
me losing during the commercial break
when the Unspeakable
act the ultimate disrespect of getting
shed during a commercial
break guys ready to
go
dance and
[Music]
the I don't like it I knew it's the
honey part of it I don't like bro that
shit's so good really it's too
sweet someone want mine oh I want to try
the new one I guess so take a bite yeah
I just took a bite you could cut I don't
care here take all this all cancer
to me trying to lose weight
chickfight no
Shredder here take this take these two
if you don't mind eat these
sa I'm
good s
[Music]
good
um video of Ian and Cam and love after
we
lost crushing
defeat
uh oh
my you like it no it's too sweet right
it's gross I'm sorry yeah I mean I
wouldn't order
that we're talking about Chick-fil-A's
new Honey
pimento yeah taste cheese and
sweetness here's poor Ian we have Jess
savan and Dan how's everyone feeling I
got a great I was really just going ask
if anyone needed a bathroom break I can
hear the sounds of the waiters FL up the
water glasses so I'm sure that's very
triggery and I would offer you guys a
chocolate bar to help your blood sugar
but Linda already took that so I'm just
going to say I'm rooting for everybody
mostly because I'm just not middle they
Ian has his head down on the
table an utter an utter he's speechless
and as I mean what was going through
your mind at the time of the end well I
mean we were looking so cool we were
feeling so good top of the world we
walked to the award show and the first
thing you know we thought we were
looking like really like bougie high
rollers and we got in line and the first
thing someone at the event said to us
was like are you hiding a rabbit in your
jacket you guys going to do some tricks
who the said that to you I don't
remember who it was but right out the
gate it set a tone and it never fully
bounc back after that
really desserts on the table were good
though delicious they're okay they're
two tiny things I don't want you guys
are freaking about I didn't like them
they were it was like Costco yeah
the sh one was no the moose was so good
lemon dessert come on like it was mid as
straight up from
cost n that I ate both of them one
bite D palette what the dude oh you
ate them all yeah I was there for like
two hours a quantity issue for you well
no they were gross too but it was like
one by dessert I need at least no
shashimi desserts yeah it's just
up just not not
right I'm sorry Ian I really think no
I'm not sorry you're the one that made
me go you apologize I really think the
third one is going to be the year though
I'm like really feeling year because
this will be like our 10th time being
nominated for something no the third
time we attend I'm not attending you
know I say quite frankly I did enjoy it
but dressing up was too much and just
felt like we spent all this time getting
the suits all that for nothing
right I'll pull
excuse it was for nothing he's right we
got dude the way they treated us a head
full of memories what you put on a suit
for them yeah well glad I didn't that's
interesting your outfit was sick though
let's talk about it what was that what
was that set it was uh Mac uh Vivian
Maxwell
amazing let's Westwood West oh yeah
Vivian westw whatever
you guys know what I'm talking about yep
I I thought you know me and Sean thall
we were we we look good dressed up you
look good you look great mhm everyone
looked great we all looked great it was
a stunning night it was YouTube's
sexiest night I think we all looked
great I agree I didn't say nobody looked
didn't look good it was YouTube's
hottest night I mean that is that is a
reward unto itself to look that hot Li
can you take this for me yeah I have my
shirt open I was showing off my star
David all the other fellow Jewish people
came up to me and you know it was fun
which was everyone because it's
Hollywood am I right yeah everyone wait
did you really have people coming up to
you cuz they saw your star da pretty
much yeah what yeah is that like the I
didn't realize that was like the Jew bat
no it's the bat signal yeah yeah it's
like a Freemason handshake o o I don't
like to identify myself as a Jew I keep
that close to the vest fair enough you
know what I mean
um here's a video of when me when I met
Jay shett so we were uh getting ready to
go down the red carpet and J shett comes
cruising by so fast and so he he walked
past us and we all start going Shetty
Shetty and he turned around and I ran
over there and we were able to um to
connect on a spiritual level
did you get lost in his eyes I told him
you have beautiful eyes
bro I try not to get lost in his I
wanted to be present in the moment it's
hard it's hard not to I don't think this
is the right
link H the one of me meeting J shed it
doesn't seem
right it's this picture of
Ian yeah that's wrong video hold on the
right
[Music]
one
you just we'll Circle back to it go to
the next one for now
um album of moments oh we were all
taking photos and stuff so here let me
open
this people haven't seen our our full
getups yet so here yeah here's the
here's the Vibes Dan and uh Ali stunning
orange top hat
monacle
slay here they are the Monopoly guys or
the peanut
guys all we know is they hate the
poor we detest the poor amen without a
doubt my did we mention there was a
strike outside the the the hotel
the hotel workers on strike yeah and you
guys cruised up like Monopoly
guy like an walking past them
excuse me peasant I feel super wor Bring
the Noise elsewhere worst case
scenario there is Dan enjoying and Ian
of
course
enjoying the Titanic being born rich I
kept trying to light up their cigars for
them but they they didn't want to do it
I think you should have now
no oh yeah when we
arrived we couldn't there was a fire
alarm going off we couldn't Park such a
disaster dudee
here I am with
jet I like his outfit I can't
lie he's all done up in this guy kid
super I thought he looked pretty
good you
know and then I was like I wonder if kid
super styled him
personally he does have that clout for
no
reason for literally no reason
here we are with makeup bag she was
awesome that's so sick that's full
circle she was actually super sweet she
asked for the photo I love her
really she was really nice she was so
nice the girls the ladies had to get get
in on it a big moment looking stunning
everybody this is I mean yeah he came up
in the mask and I I just couldn't
believe what I was seeing Frank frankly
I said bro we know what you look
like it's just so embarrassing go
right okay like dude it the the mask
thing is
done it was already embarrassing but now
it's like Mega embarrassing I personally
can't wait for his second second face
reveal it's like in a year or two
plastic like an upate face reveal yeah
well he took it off during the show last
night yeah he realized how dumb was even
him please take off your
mask and of course we left during
because the after the ultimate
disrespect because again we all went and
got dinner together which was great fun
time
y there's a million things I'd rather be
doing on a Sunday night than sitting
watching Among Us
jokes in an institution with nothing but
disrespect I miss my Columbo re
run Columbo yeah somebody on the subr
posted this and I have to
say I think my posture is good but are
they maybe exaggerating his lean cuz he
also looks pretty straight nah you think
he's leaning in yeah I think that's
accurate that's sick you see this
Jay this is the real
analysis this is the real award right
here that poer is just not showing hey
Jay don't let your wife see this bro she
not going to be happy one bit
nope uh this comment was funny subreddit
I just know ELO won't be able to drag
Ethan out of the house for a good 6
months after this I said more like six
years we out this empty
table we bailed them yeah we got we
got food
yeah and they didn't us they they
tricked I feel tricked and disrespected
so why should we sit there yeah they
even cut to our empty table which kind
of awesome during the show mhm this was
me freak I was like oh we're pretty far
from the front oh no literally lost to J
shed during a commercial break my worst
nightmar has
happened but here I am wow powerful yeah
he's a good he was nice he was nice he's
nice yeah he was nice I sent the video
in chat we finally meet I know he got my
head a little cuz I was like what do you
mean it was magic we finally meet that's
almost like a super villain thing he was
different finally meet I think you might
be the super villain in this
maybe well would Batman say that to the
Joker we finally he doesn't yeah I guess
maybe it be it would be the other way
maybe he's showing a little bit of Joker
brain too maybe he's kind of in on it he
likes the beef that's what I got out of
it yeah cuz he can high road me
yeah well we' probably sent him a lot of
new fans too because we talk all the
and then people go check it out and
they see how hot he is and watch this
now he's hot and motivational
dude by the way if you want to talk
about promoting the streamy I don't
think anybody promoted that as hard
as we
did no uh yeah probably not I mean
goddamn we talked about it for weeks
right here I am flexing my uh socks and
sandals I went socks sandals and shorts
I kept it real as
possible Ela looks amazing she did look
really really
good I tried everything in my power to
get out of
this here this is it
right you so cool it's all you deserve
it oh my God you guys look amazing nice
shot by uh wow what do you got in that
drink
um I was filming but I was trying to
remain really discreet cuz I didn't want
him to know that we were videotaping I
knew that he knew that pictures were
being taken I didn't want it to be weird
I don't know trying to be low key yes
and that's Sam's hand that's my hand
holding water and Olivia was holding the
camera like right behind my hand yeah
like holding it low to my chest it's the
biggest drink of night of the year yeah
I don't think he cared cuz we taking aot
I think about it but in the moment it
felt shed's always on you're right you
know I mean I should have known you have
beautiful
eyes stunning eyes you deserve it no you
deserve it see he's mind you
there he's high roing me he's mind
you he knows what he's doing
this he probably knew he
won there I think they told him I kind
of no he yeah but he knew he went cuz
he's J shete yeah exactly no he didn't
have he didn't it's easy be oh I hope
you win I hope you win uh-huh sure you
do yeah right right sure you
do should have told him I hope you
lose i h rooted
[Applause]
him
amaz creeper
[Music]
shot what do you guys think about him
wearing like super high-end designer I
think he looks cuz he's a I love the
outfit but he's like a motivational
speaker why is he out here flexing his
wealth he's like a guru he's Mo that's
is he a wealth is he like a wealth
gospel guy I mean what's the deal I
don't think so you sure I mean can he
not motivate you to slay yeah in like
awesome Street Wear like what you
talking about I liked his outfit I'm
just saying it's a little
phony I know you're sad I'm not sad you
can be
sad I'm happy for sh sad I'm happy for
shett um let's
see this is the winners we saw that this
is by the way here's my prediction of
what would happen
on
Friday
mhm listen to every word of
this let me go back here
okay they're going to do it during a
commercial and shed's going to win
during a commercial break do we leave if
that happens can we leave can we storm
out um I I that's that's exactly what I
said would happen it's almost like they
were watching called
it me dude WIS during a commercial
break cuz that's the tri that's the
Perfection of disrespect
are you walking out with me Dan if
Shetty wins during the commercial no I'm
applaud I am fully behind Shetty I I
hope he wins Dan's trying to get a
job not he doesn't work with bald
people that's not true oh you know he
does I know for a fact cuz um you know
someone who who's bald that works for
him yeah you I see hold on I got to
respond to somebody real quick uhhuh
hey Dan I listen you want to come uh
produce a uh Dar man
video we're paying 12250 an
hour that's below minimum wage yeah no
we found a work
around
um Ethan patiently waiting to get
by the
streames oh this yeah all the red carpet
stuff this was pretty funny man I never
done I've never done anything like this
she's just been around forever I have
been a fan and then she just came up to
me before I carpeted and was like can't
wait to hang out tonight and I'm just
like I can't believe you're saying that
to me I'm just like I've loved her
forever she's she's an
OG yeah what do you do I mean I was
just standing there what do you
do the red carpet is interesting though
you do the
photos and then there's like a whole
line of people with cameras and
mics and then they ask you like do
you want this baby to
die obviously
no we'll get to
that apparently yeah uh the foer
Troopers are saying that
uh it lost 5,000 10,000 views that's
what I was saying 36k to
24K I was watching it it didn't have
more than 40K when I was me too yeah I
got clarification they there were two
streams they the streamy channel was
streaming it and then it was also being
streamed on map I watch on M hat okay
well one one had higher views than the
other huh
okay so they
claim the whole chat was foot soldiers
thank you guys for representing the
family
Tomatoes oh man when J shett was
presenting you guys went
wild stop with the tomatoes you're
killing
me I'm sorry jay Shetty
uh it's not about you it's it's about
it's it's it's it's me it's not you to
make an Tom the elate price foundation
is increasing their monetary
investment to over1
million
stop 1 million fueling initiatives like
the ones you'll see led by our nominees
tonight there it
is love you guys for that apologies to
Chet oh the crew meets iow speed's dad
this was an interesting uh crossover
here check this out I guess his dad was
live streaming yeah and then we were
sitting right next to them
and you guys were constantly in the
background of his his live and I guess
they
were yeah saying something to
him this Chad was saying that we were
buying him and he finally caught
[Music]
on he looks so much like speed yeah
which you know it's his dad there's some
clips with him and uh speed that's so
funny is his dad funny I anything about
him well he's acting like a little bit
of a conservative dad kind of or not
conservative but like laidback and then
speed does all these crazy oh they
have like he does a straight man little
bit of a I don't know if it's um a
sketch type thing or not but yeah
yeah that's the
H3
[Music]
he like who are these
goons the top
hats uh Ian and I show speed's Dad
mixing it
up you know what were you guys talking
about just asked him sort of like what
so what speed sort of routine for
writing things and like past he look
like for his team like is there any are
they looking for people or would he ever
go multi-cam need someone to kind of
around that's all I'm kind of doing it
word for word there just checking in
right that's another reason I shouldn't
let you guys go you all are just looking
for a better job you probably you
probably all have secret business cards
you hand it out to everyone all
night yo give this to speed his chat was
funny because it was all like this he's
talking to the what is he talking to Abe
Lincoln at the table behind him right
funny
lh3 got
him got
him um there was there was one uh
screenshot I saw on Reddit from that
live it said like are the Jews behind
you or something like that like I don't
jokeing there was some like anti-semitic
yeah doesn't surprise me oh here's
the infamous uh video I was talking
about the interviewer was very nice the
question did take me by surprise they
asked me
like three random like what's your
advice to a Creator just getting
started oh I'm very happy for that she's
beautiful I agree uh just watch J shett
I
guess and then she goes what do you
think about Malibu Barbie I was like the
they cut that out I was like you
mean like Trisha's baby or the movie
what do you mean what are you saying
genuinely just shocked me oh I'm very
happy for them she's beautiful I agree
uh there's nothing more I mean listen we
have two kids a third on the way there's
nothing uh more sacred and beautiful in
the world than a than a baby so I'm very
happy so scummy to ask that so
weird I mean it's true what I said
obviously Beau that was a classy
response it's true yeah she's
beautiful and I'm sure she's a precious
perfect little baby that's true that's
true that's
true um Dan's Dome was spotted at the
streaming that's pretty funny oh here's
another one of me talking about uh
on the red
carpet everybody asked me questions and
I made every single response I did to
every interview about J Shetty it is the
only thing I talked about on that red
carpet they asked me what do they ask me
J
shett yeah yeah he's it's all that's all
that matters sorry I know and he's got
the best smoothie his eyes are insanely
beautiful unbelievable I mean it's hard
to believe did he get like a eye surgery
no you know they can do that where they
like they can laser out the pigment it's
all real yeah huge fan fan doesn't even
describe really we're just shed heads
I'm a
devotee I'm a uh fanatic these edits are
sh
heads I love that just like
like pop up scare audio dog what's
with the bad audio and the edits very
odd y'all got like a professional
looking mic but it sounds like dooo yeah
I love it have you met him no no it's
going to be my hopefully my first time I
don't know I'm
nervous to me he's the they put in the
work whoever edited this yeah yeah I
think this is and no disrespect to
anyone I talked to that night they
followed through he's the guru he's down
to earth J shett made a video about the
importance of um working together with
your partner okay and ultimately that's
what I credit our good long relationship
with so I I I I just I remember one of
his older classic videos I would say J
shett they included
this that's that's real uh foot soldier
Behavior huh
oh ela's coming oh
fantastic we love
that oh I don't think she's going to
counterbalance he's with me Dan's dumb
was spotted in the wild this is
fantastic take a look
here I know that Dome from
anywhere dud that was
awesome wait that was that
ruled that Dome hell yeah
that
Dome El is
here I'm still bitching about the
streames yeah you come sit next to me
it's all ready for
you
um Ela just sat down hello you got
something you want to say about the it's
funny cuz I was just ranting to tayor
about it we were just sitting downstairs
talking about it
I didn't I wasn't
listening cuz I just finished emitting
so I don't know what was said so
far also why does it smell like um
coming up into McDonald's coming up the
stairs we did a Chick-fil-A thing do you
have anything left oh we might actually
I didn't
finish do you want a chicken sandwich we
can you just cut around it or is there
is it not worth saving
yeah so then it's probably good let's go
right now pregnant Ela is a wild beast
man wild I'm hungry
like asking for Chick-fil-A leftovers
that's crazy out of character so I like
the boys never finish their food and
usually I just you know throw it out
this this time lately everything they
don't finish I'm just like that's me let
me finish real quick your plate every
body's running up their leftovers to
ELA just cut just with the knife cut
off so just cut it around yours or you
want to eat it like that
Ela yeah I mean yeah we share everything
anyway sure cut off Love's part just for
not that you have coties but you know
just to be keep it clean just for
formality you're Sweedish we don't know
what's in your
saliva oh this is so yeah I mean what
did you want to say we talked about a
lot I mean what is there to say you were
right 100% right you were right
literally and there's a reason we've
never gone and we probably will never go
I'm never g i no yeah no respect for
them as an institution right one of my
over one question that I find myself
pondering who deciding the winner of
these I wonder that too
cuz like so many people there were fans
of the podcast and listen to the podcast
yeah apparently everybody in the world
is a fan and watch yeah and so like so
who is making the decisions then oh
thanks love well I saw J shett with a
doing a selfie with the CEO yeah the CEO
we didn't get to talk to and he was like
they were like buddied up so I says is J
shett on the council oh is J shett have
poll with the council that's possible
you know J shett was on Ellen
no that doesn't surprise me J sh is
connected like that he's so connected J
shed Allen I just don't even know
why I mean have you seen his
eyes I
have here he is oh I'll get claimed so
fast but here I just want to show you
guys oh he was so he's evolved wait so
here this was one year
ago on Ellen's show on Ellen tube as
Ellen's show comes to close was this her
final
episode J Shetty talked about how we
tend to forget final guest that dude
this was her final
guest J shett talks about how we tend to
forget that the end of anything is the
beginning of something else he is her
last
guess as Ellen's show comes to a
close and while letting go of something
is hard holding on is harder the host of
onp purpose podcast talked about what
you can do right now for mental health
awareness answered some audience
questions and surprised Ellen with a
donation to The Trevor Project in her
honor I it I don't think he was the last
guest I'm finding an article about her
last episode Jennifer
and it may have been uh the last week or
something that's their new sandwich it's
like a honey what did you guys think
about it I didn't like it personally but
some people like it yeah I don't like it
either I don't love the sweet that kind
of like weirded me out it's just honey
but yeah it's not my vibe so how close
was it to the end no this was from May
3rd
2020 uh the final episode was on May 26
or 25th I guess cuz the article they
were on the final he got the final run
like the last like month he didn't get
the premium
spot dude you need a picture of J shete
while he's sitting there how many J
shetes we need even pregnant this one's
not working for me there it is yeah wait
what's the daily J this man have
multiple podcast the daily Jay with J
Shetty this man cannot stop saying his
name the daily Jay with J shett starring
J
shett today's guest J
shett
um and then let's see here here us
walking out I can get
over not reading the podcast category
like one of the biggest C category of
the event the evening I don't understand
like what are we talking about well some
of the ones they read off were just
like clearly not as they showed you
YouTubers playing video games screaming
at the screen like it's 10 years ago
like well there was ones that make even
less sense than the yeah like the I
don't remember even but there were a lot
that didn't make a lot first person one
was probably the strangest first person
there was a category called first person
I didn't know yeah what does that even
mean even the guy who presented said I
don't understand what this award
is here we are bailing on the
streamy I'm up I'm
out I got better to do on
Sunday um I mean sitting there waiting
was a little bit of a torture
so yeah dude and they had to put it at
the end too you could at least killed me
at the beginning of the show right
um here they showed the empty table
during the broadcast how awesome is that
dude we are all gone no wait is this our
table cuz who the are
they uh yeah I don't recognize the yeah
no not actually our table no
okay also all the treats are still on
the plate and we hate that so
apparently there was another table of
people that left oh really because there
were there were a decent amount of
people in the lobby after true when we
met out there so probably other people
leaving that's true there were people
also there wasn't even like food while
we're sitting there right you know I'm
pregnant I'm like the whole time I'm
like okay what am I
eating yeah I'm with you here's a new uh
button screen by the way I thought that
was pretty good we'll be right back
pretty good I like that that's
cute I'll add that
tomorrow what what did the Cru say today
were you guys did you have fun at
least had a lot of fun yeah blast and
then there's this tweet that Olivia had
to a delete what happened here wait you
deleted it okay so the thing about this
tweet is I got it cleared with Ethan
before it even went out yeah and then I
I felt like post Tweet Clarity and I was
like you know what he may look like a
winner but I may not want to be saying
that M he look good yeah he looks like a
winner L it's true
you also look like a winner I'm just
saying I saw J shett for the first time
and he looks like a
winner he does just walks like he owns
the place he's good that but he does he
sh he does own the place he probably
does those people are all on
payroll shedy is funding the streames so
that's basically it I think I've said it
all
how extreme was your most extreme
statement today I didn't have to hit the
button okay so we're good I don't think
it was that bad right guys then no
okay okay some of the interviewers were
like what's your most controversial
YouTube moment I was like are you
serious you want me to say she's like
yeah just be as candid as possible I was
like well this one time about Ben
Shapiro and then there was this other
time about where I said this about the
NRA and they were like shocked
I was like you
asked definitely not making the
cut oh then there's another one where
they're like do you have any advice to
uh up incoming YouTubers I said yeah
don't don't try to uh find uh minors to
have sex with in Instagram
DMS Jesus Christ and then they go all
right well thanks I said by the way have
you I said by the way have you guys uh
talked to James Charles yet today
yeah you said that
we won't see that video it was fun
though that's wild
um I think the audience at least
um they get it you guys get me
right I think everybody gets you thank
you
unfortunately I didn't want that to be
the case the word I you know what's sad
I I thought for a minute that they
weren't going to do us like that me too
I had hopes they y yed one they y yed
two and I was like maybe there's no more
y Yas
yeah they y we were in the last y yada
is actually probably the most
disrespectful
exactly so it's like a trifecta hatrick
of
disrespect Tom Wards is out here saying
the streams love that oh yo wow H
yeah Tommy Boy the boys are looking good
wa wait you got to read that read the
caption dance word love love violence
Cameron grants of the a podcast me we're
in Getty baby love Island yeah what the
you're an island boy not an island
boy ladies and gents we got
him I hadn't seen this yet I wanted us
all to do the red carpet together but
y'all were so damn late and I was like
you're the you guys are the ones wanted
me here damn late ass and uh Allie's
ticket um for some reason didn't have
the red carpet approval so they wouldn't
let her into that area ditch her out
there so yeah that sucked we were trying
to make it happen over well they did the
same thing to Shantal and we had to call
somebody no I talked to the dude up at
the front oh right and I'm like yo hook
us up he's like I got you I don't know
why they did that I should have
done that oh well what is this I haven't
seen this for the record is prodat oh
wait no this is a this is a
Photoshop yeah what
I thought it was a produciton suite A
large complex detailed by utable report
on the streamers Awards frauds which
took place in Los
Angeles is almost complete and I'll be
present this is a Mike pillow thing I
it's either Mike pillow or uh I think
actually didn't uh didn't Trump have a
tweet just like this last week based on
the result of this conclusive report all
best podcast stream awards are crooked J
shed shall be dropped and awarded to H3
the random capitalizations uh makes me
think this is a trump tweet it's written
like my pillow though it is yeah Trump
tweeted this that's so
crazy like if you just imagine I wrote
this how crazy that is and we're talking
about some silly award show he's talking
about an
election there will be a complete
reversal they never went after those who
rigged the streames they only went after
those that fought to find the riggers
could I sh uh tweet this actually no
it's pretty funny why it's important
message for the
world no good people might not know the
reference I wouldn't have known the
reference did he lose his mind okay
shout out to this clip how people God
this is like one of the funniest
that was so weird I thought that maybe
Ethan didn't hear them right cuz I was
like there's no way that's what they
asked I asked her to clarify yeah I was
just like stunned like I was just out of
nowhere here's how here's how the people
interviewing me thought I would react y
why is he looking at me like that what's
up little bud you got a staring problem
pal like what dude he's just looking at
you he's a baby he look at his face dumb
little
face stop yo Zan get your
boy
stop this was a YouTube show I yeah yeah
that's getter I know right nice guy good
guy real Bros the seei valley yeah
that's right
I'm fine the US debriefing about the
streaming today you know I'm fine if I
lose to Kanye or someone that
I'm like okay I respect that I know who
that is and Kanye has a huge following
he's made a massive impact on
music fine I'm good with that but don't
get us all here to use your
selling point for your show and
stiff everybody every single
time and I said after that point in time
I was like don't ever ask me to
come here again please do not ask me my
answer is no for a 100 million years
right fcking to the wait what did they
do to emem I'm fine sounds like exactly
what streamis just did to us J shete won
there winner for for best uh musical
album of the Year J Shetty
meditations man whale sounds by J
shett so are you never going to cons not
streaming I'm not worried I don't care
about the stream it's dead to me too I'm
not going either what other okay but if
anything else comes up is what are the
Chan who I'm a huge I mean it depends
what it is okay okay I like that it's
that wasn't a straight up no oh this guy
was really nice uh obviously I don't
watch wrestling but apparently he's a
WWE guy and uh super nice guy fan of the
show he said really really nice he was
very nice and also Gard watch I Didn't
Know did she just post this yeah I I
checked she posted it this morning girl
kle who I'm a huge fan of I love the H3
podcast in chat here I can send you the
full video I have I got to meet Ethan
Klein who I'm a huge fan of3
podcast at least she won it was nice
meeting uh yeah this Goblin mode to me
well I was God
Tom I got to watch this Tom WS
video
[Applause]
babby my laptop appears to be frozen
this Dell bro you got a Dell
dude you're getting a Dell do you want
me to buy you a new laptop should I get
a new one I mean we don't need to buy a
new one yes kind of an important element
of show it works fine maybe just a a
mouse what the hell just get a proper
laptop all right I got to close my
browser I might have to restart this
thing
why is this stuck like
this what the why don't you use
this beautiful Mac I think I have to
restart it it's that Frozen what the
wait why is there a Mac there I
don't know why don't you use this whose
Mac is that next to
me you can't use that doesn't have the
plugs uh
yeah it's the one that you used to use
but it it's having all kinds of problems
so I need to restart D I don't know what
that means for you it it's fine okay
so I'm going to go ahead and restart
this it won't even let me click the
button okay we got to do a forced wow
what is this question El thoughts on
double booking the streams what does
that mean double booking the streams
about having them next year at the same
time the steamies oh so this is my I'm
I'm on a war path with them so next year
I'm moving the steamies mhm
to co-program
the streamings same time we're going
live
mhm yeah it's War bro we'll see who gets
more live views too
I swear to god
dude how I don't even where's the power
button thing but you know what could be
really epic is if it actually has like
real life
audience where literally where's the
power
button
okay get out here I don't know how to
hold the but oh that's a weird spot
what's weird it's like part of the
keyboard that's where it always is what
it it's not the top right corner how did
I instantly know where it was then
because you you said the number spot I
would
check there is only one key to um I
think if you really want to diss them
though we got to make it like an actual
event and invite cool people to come I
was wondering if we could do it with
like a live audience yeah and then do it
in a venue close to the Stream that'd be
nuts that'd be crazy thing to do
yeah and our event we actually have like
a lot of people attending what's the PIN
number dang it with your
hands that wasn't
correct got
[Music]
Ito I don't know if I want to put that
much effort in though to be honest wait
it's still here look oh I restarted it's
still
here yeah it's frozen still in the same
exact
[Music]
way all right I'll come I'll come
intervene here did the computer actually
restart though it doesn't seem like it's
not restarting it's just turning off and
on there's got to be a force slide to
shut down your
PC I tried sliding with both
dude you got a Dell dude all dude you're
getting a
Dell bro with these grades I'm sorry son
you're getting a
Dell thank you
[Music]
Zach it would be a lot of effort but
like all of us would dress just as nice
we got to convince like all these people
to come to yeah other YouTubers people
nominated Friends of the show I don't
know probably not our thing is talking
right maybe you know be funny if we just
like copied their show yeah yeah like
same Awards same winners mhm but we
would actually do like actual categories
like podcast like no just copy their
show well I think I'm saying we could do
it and do it better we could just change
a few things right but it I think it
would be a funny uh parody to literally
just watch their stream and copy their
show wouldn't that be awesome yeah with
the GRE G or would you make it better
just the winners the same categories the
same
winners I don't get that at the same
time so people don't watch the
streams they watch
us I get that
yeah yeah it's parody we good it's it
could be a lawsuit I'd have to look
what's funny about that personally it's
pretty funny
I kind of like it it's like so spiteful
and dumb yes that's why it's funny I
think we need to actually
start an award show that's not cringy no
see even see I'm I don't want to go down
that route and then be like somebody
else should do it yeah not me I don't
want to be that guy yeah I know I don't
want to be that
[Music]
guy streamy
uh here's J shett man at the
Tony
Awards is that what these are the gramms
the gramms like what for whale sounds
bro you beat Eminem with whale sounds
okay I guess that makes
sense on purpose with J
shett
um okay oh we have a call in with the
Gizzy guy we do uh when's he calling in
as soon as we're done with the segment
okay fantastic so uh basically so
basically
guys well actually we're going to do a
little celebration
here you know because it just so happens
you might not know this at
home
that I'm just seeing if there's any
other memes we
missed that um today is a very special
day in
fact wait where's my stuff got
moved today is
actually
um
Zach's fifth fiveyear anniversary at the
show yes it is oh thank
you and to pay homage to you
Zach party music we
[Music]
okayy what's in here you taking your
shirt off I don't want to wear a shirt
on a
shirt just not
like oh my God so everybody is putting
on Hawaiian oh my God we all have WIS
we're all we are all we are all you Zach
oh my God we are all Zack that's so nice
this is us this is Dam your hair looks
the
same oh my
god
wow oh my God looking good man is this
what it's like to have long hair when
you just always doing this how do you
deal with this I uh I put mine like to
the side not to that
degree you look good oh my god dude it's
crazy what is happening why is that
happening why is they doing that oh my
God this is so nice yeah well
congratulations Zach we honor you thank
you five
years five years with Zach a great guy
thank you an amazing sound guy
Ian truly the show would not be the same
thank you and uh we we love you buddy
thank you I love you guys it's very
sweet we thank you for for 5 years of of
faithful service a it's an honor to be
working we also got you a present ooh
something that I think you might might
like is someone bringing it out yeah we
got you a special little something to
celebrate 5 years oh my God I like that
you're wearing your Rolex hat today do
you have to own a Rolex to wear a Rolex
hat I I guess not but you know I do so
there it is what is this I don't know
for you to open and find out
Minecraft yep where just tear it open I
can't find a a good G oh here we go so
Zach is opening his present oh my God
the Pacman that's right buddy Pacman
dude we got Zach the ultimate Lego set
oh my God he's been after you've been
after this right Zach I
have oh my God thank you so much oh
yeah dude let's see it so holy
that's cool you just build giant arcade
yeah the David Pacman dude the David
Pacman Ted experience thank you guys so
much it's so nice this is
awesome it's our pleasure
congratulations thank you very
much very sweet Years thank you five
years of greatness dude that's amazing
how's it been for you Zach five years
it's been truly an honor um I I I get
emotional thinking about it because it
I'm not bullshitting it's really
been nothing but extraordinary and um
I'm doing things I never thought a
million years I could be doing so it's
been really it's been really nice and um
I work with a great group of people I
love my job I get to be creative and
dumb um crazy and um it's just
amazing so thank you well thank you Zach
thank you wouldn't be the same without
you for real it seems like just
yesterday a dyed young boy dropped out
of college and came to control our audio
levels yep yep and uh it blost them
didn't it yeah it's it's been um it's
been an amazing ride Z thank you zachie
Zachary You Gonna Leave the wig on the
whole show uh feel it out that's pretty
annoying I feel like I'm doing a weird L
cosplay right now more than anything oh
wow you do see
that uh yeah but I'm liking the here
yours is crazy love the blonde facial
hair become someone new the blonde
facial hair with the dark hair is a wild
look up
[Laughter]
Dad is it like this though like if you
shake your hair and it gets in your face
is it really that hard to get out no it
can be annoying sometimes yeah I find it
the most annoying when I when I'm
sleeping like when my head's on the
pillow my hair is just always in my face
oh I have to put my hair up when I go to
bed see I can't do that because the the
rubber band gives me a headache you
should get a scrunchie yeah I've tried
that I I get I don't know it's a weird
we'll talk about it do you have a
scrunchie I can borrow cuz this is going
in my face do you sleep with scrunchie I
do know that my hair is long but before
I didn't what's your strategy I braid it
now I do a braid before I go to sleep a
braid is yours not long his hair is
short yeah your is not long enough for a
braid huh no trantel braids my hair h
braid it I I will uh next time there it
is I don't know how to braid but he does
it for me it's not like a fancy braid
you just kind of wrap it up like a like
a hollow bread exactly yeah yeah basic
one but thank you guys very much this is
this is amazing we love you Zach
love you zie thank you thank you thank
you thank you play your favorite sound
bite to honor yourself if you were doing
the sounds for yourself what would you
play right now where's that hold on
where's that fan noise coming from it
was me oh okay my favorite sound bite if
you were playing the audio for
yourself oh what would you play cheers
my dude yeah there love you no
homoa I mean it's the goat it's the
absolute goat that when people see me in
person they just say cheers my
dude really yeah oh that's awesome yeah
so but yeah thank you guys very much
it's been an honor working here and to
many many more years to come and I'm
seeing AB is also honoring you from home
here on the zoom feed just noticed he
busted out the Hawai I didn't have a wig
sorry buddy you look more like Magnum PI
I figured I figured youd like that too
but love you buddy love you too
man actually looking at this Trixie got
screwed over in the same way did I just
lose best show at the streamers for the
fourth time absolutely I did well she at
least had the good uh foresight to not
attend you know what I mean yeah
uh here's a peak streamy moment let's
take a look at the the Great Moments
that defined the
evening creator of the year
is Mr
[Applause]
[Music]
Beast I really thought it was going to
be J shedy by the
way you know if you're going to keep
giving him Awards he really needs to
show up
he
didn't he didn't ask for the award guys
you know what I mean you know just cuz
dumbass award show gives you award you
don't need to come oh that it should
tell you something about the status of
this he didn't even send in a thank
you video he's like no I'm not attending
this I'm Mr Beast bro he did make a
tweet about it I get a tweet well you
should see what the Tweet was okay let
me see it tell to suck it cuz we didn't
get
best he was very he was really
enthusiastic about winning
here go ahead there it
is so here it is he won for the fourth
year in a row fourth year in a row
hi he doesn't care it's a comment it's
not even a tweet he literally doesn't
care about you guys he's not going to
you stop making him crat of the he
doesn't he's not going to you he's
not coming to your event
EV that's pretty crazy dude I love him
for
that oh
man I'll tell you what streaming don't
even try to make it up to me next year
I'm not tweeting I'm not acknowledging
it you make you make me podcast winner
I'm not tweeting it I will probably talk
about it for a whole week leading up
though yep so probably the best and the
rest of us will be attending here we are
this one looks photoshopped I don't know
no this
photoshopped why do you say that
something a weird you actually look that
good yeah no you look great in person
too yeah yeah no you look like that like
today here I just look a little short I
mean I knew Ela was wearing high was
going to be taller than me MH well yeah
know shorter than usual I don't
know okay right you look good dude don't
worry about it all right thank you hip
height oh you know what and I I was
telling them I almost wore a suit for
them but I got got it right I got to
wear suit into the show just for no
reason I think you should go like that
man you should grow your hair out and
you look good let me see it's scaring
me what's scaring you that I'm looking
over and like if I blur my eyes they're
two brunettes with longer hair and Ela
has had hair that short before so it's
like there are two if I really really
squint two different elas this is us I'm
getting a little hot and bothered by you
Ethan it look great I'm understand I
understand you want to get coffee or
something
sometime no I'm good you're going to
have to do better than
that um let's see so I guess that's
about it yeah I need an explanation of
how J shett gets the celebs and still
not hitting millions of views yet gets
podcast of the Year multiple times hey
well Tom
Ward practically had the president on
too but I agree this the the level of
celebrity he has on vers the amount of
views he gets is definitely some Tom
Ward
status no offense Tom Ward we love you
but you know what just goes to show
don't give up Tom Ward you two could I'm
very happy for them you know I agree
play your cards right and you could beat
me for best podcast this
year yeah I think that's it I think
that's everything thing oh this was kind
of funny the streamy did this promo
video um with all these
stunning red carpet looks it's a rainy
day Los Angeles striking a
pose and it's me twiddling my
thumbs I don't know what to do why that
one why that one I think that's all
there was to be fair I don't think there
was a lot more to work
with
but there that was used in her hot pink
dress that is very true get your hands
off her bro what the is
this bro Chill on my
girl EXC sleeping we love that for
him Ethan's look big compared to shett
now that's
photoshopped yo and Alpa grip too
somebody noticed whoa that is an alpha
grip hold on look how big my hand looks
compared to him yeah
what the we got to frame this it's
photosho dude no it's not yes it is no
it's not it's clear listen so show me
the original then if you're such a
genius sure cam can you uh send that cam
yeah send the edited one yeah Ken send
us the edit Dan I like your pulled back
look man it looks really good I I feel
like I look like um like one of the
goons in like an 8s movie like I'm like
it's like a crime paper in like Miami
and I roll up with like another guy
dressed the same way you look like uh
James gandal finini in True Romance
there you go here let me pull that
up uh but seriously Sam can we print
this out and make a um frame this blow
this up is she here yeah she's here you
copy that okay good yeah that's
important I'll put that above my bed
first thing I see in the morning my
giant hands hulking over
his okay I will be leaving now all right
Ela love you no homo no homo love
you what's for
dinner cuz clearly that sh play in hit
don't know yeah I'm thinking what's
right now what's for right now I'm going
to go eat something right now I haven't
had Mexican food in so
long you know what I mean mhm can bother
but just thinking about
it as long as there's no nipple no you
can pop on nip too you pop a nip no I'm
trying to keep it yeah pop a ni
appropriate for all ages oh okay right I
need the sticky so that like it just
rides it like right there yeah you just
ride it right on the edge right and it
won't ever
move I always wondered how women did
that where they wear these tops where
it's like it's right there but like the
nipple never comes out and then I
realized or I discovered one day that
there's like tape a tape yeah
tricks they got all kinds of Tricks they
got titty tricks women yeah we're
deceiving it's true I mean know it's
clever it's I mean literally you don't
want accidents that's embarrassing C cun
creatures the cunning is off the
charts all right get out of here with
your titty tricks do a titty trick for
me later you know what I mean got him
bye byea thanks for stopping in all
right let's talk to our gy champion all
right uh let me say set this up cuz we
watched this
um maybe in Monday he's a fan of the
show he was wearing a Teddy fresh Shir
and he's been going viral everyone's
reposting his
I don't think he got much credit
for that either to be honest did I ever
read this message from him I don't think
so no it was after the show that we
talked about oh he's in
Discord just proving Oh I thought I said
I read Discord in here H's number one
fan gbot
wow hi I'm Jason thebot that was
featured as the new Teddy fresh
Ambassador such a massive fan I've been
watching since long before the podcast
I've seen every single episode literally
every single shirt I own is Teddy fresh
you have no idea how incredibly happy
I'm that you all enjoyed my silly little
video so much and even dad's new
favorite sound bite slle mhm Ethan was
trying to find my Tik Tok handle because
it wasn't shown in the video my Tik Tok
is Jason reborn jason. reborn no he is
Jason reborn he says I sent the crew all
DMS on Discord he's he is a foa
trooper I think I don't know if he's a
member is the thing cuz those go
directly to my inbox and how would he
know your your Discord then oh that's a
good point well he's uh in the zoom room
so we can uh ask him cuz I'm not sure if
that's something that regy checked I've
also included the pick I took during the
episode yeah let's talk to Gizzy boy all
right let me show the video too in case
anyone didn't see it hang on a
second here is hello hello audio audio
audio hello Jason just one second we're
going to show your video right now for
people at home who didn't see here is uh
Jason reborn Gizzy Master born from the
ash of
a of a uh overcooked Gizzy I don't
knowen ice cream so good thank you for
the ice cream thank you for the heart me
I H you too thank you the
quizes
100 glizzies and dream Gizzy
[Music]
[Applause]
overdrive increasing grip by
[Music]
7% we are locked in thanking for over
160 glizzies and do a Gizzy
[Music]
overdrive think that so first of all how
long have you first of all nice to meet
you uh thank you for your wonderful work
sorry that everyone's ripping your
off listen that that video got numbered
like 30 million views on Twitter zero
credit for me it's okay though it's okay
we're doing it on our own did anything
trickle down to you at all other than
this I guess maybe maybe like a thousand
followers maybe wow that's a that
is some people even like go out of their
way to not give you credit you notice
that they like will crop out your
handle yeah but we're starting to get
some we're starting to get the
recognition that we deserve um you know
it's a slow it's a slow process but
we're getting there it's good honest
work you know what I mean it is it is
you know I go live every single day um I
do those streams intermittently
throughout the day we end up gaining
like maybe 1,500 a day you know It's a
Grind oh just me oh that the editorial
Wii the editorial we I mean I have an
amazing I have an amazing mod team um we
all work together um there's like 15
moderators um you know a close Inner
Circle keep them tight um but got more
than I do there's a lot of haters I
literally I'm only live doing that
stream for maybe two hours a day and I
get kicked off at uh Tik Tok live maybe
six seven times a day what just because
people are mass spamming reports Mass
reporting I hate that aspect of Tik Tok
man yeah and I I opened a ticket but
there's nothing there going to do so let
me ask you this how long have you been
doing the Gizzy slamming NPC
thing believe it or not maybe maybe a
month now maybe probably less not long
at all and was it an immediate success
for you was it Gizzy from the
beginning well I had I had started I
didn't i' done maybe like three or four
different uh just the normal NPC streams
you know like what you usually see like
the thank you for the rose um and it was
a very deliberate uh decision to move in
the direction of the Gizzy uh streams
and they were an immediate immediate hit
honestly like thousands of viewers every
single live
immediately that's amazing I that's one
aspect of Tik Tok I do love so how are
you making like pretty good money from
this yeah W dude the gzy over let me
tell you just this past Saturday I
received the highest Tik Tok gift you
can ever it's like $1,000 from one
person one person it was I yeah one
person dude do you know who it
was yeah yeah it's um yeah we're
following each other now oh my
God
congratulations you yeah Saturday was we
actually hit uh number 35 live in all of
the us on
Saturday so were you working what kind
of job or work were you doing before
Gizzy uh hour oh before before this I
was uh I was I was you know surviving I
was doing like instaart delivery just
kind of doing you know things here there
yeah odd jobs
um you know but I've really found my
stride with this um I'm having a blast
doing it it's so and it's paying the
bill oh it's it's going well so you're
making a lot more money than you were
before probably four times as much yo
I'm so happy for you and it was almost
immediate it was I've only been on Tik
Tok like at all for about 3 months total
that's so wild about Tik Tok honestly
how cool is that you just you find
something that works and you just like
immediately reap the benefits immediate
immediate so can I ask you this what's
the most you've made in a uh
stream um in a stream at one time yeah
well um I'm gonna I'm gonna count
Saturday um I it got cut up cuz we got
kicked cuz Mass reported I'm going to
count two the two streams as one say
about $1,300 in about an
hour good for you bro thank you hey man
you're talented at what you do brother
you know what I mean nobody's nobody
gulps bizzies like you and I really like
how you how you spit on it beforehand
thank we have a few different moves we
have a few different go-to moves and
we're always we're always looking for
more we're always trying to expand our
uh our uh our move sets absolutely
whatever you want to call it um we're
yeah we got a few different go show me
kind of a few of them cuz I've only seen
the spitting one yeah well we're going
to need some epic music um sure we can
help epic okay okay uh Zach hit him with
some epic music coming in now here it is
you hear that thank you for
thees thees enty
overdrive so yeah okay that's the basic
and then we go we go into Gluck luck
overdrive
where oh wow wait wait wait wait
wait wait I didn't hear it hold on yeah
there's something there's something
critical here I didn't hear the glug GL
I I want to get this clean for the audio
so I'm going to cut z z Zack I have I
have clean recordings I'm trying to send
them to you uh let me know your email
nice all right cool yeah yeah so the
thing is is that Zoom does the uh Echo
cancel and like the glug gug hitting
yeah yeah so hold on on I'm turning that
off right now so that we can get a pure
unadulterated the AI doesn't believe
those are human sounds um here I'm
turning off Echo
cancellation High Fidelity music mode is
on okay I think
theoretically and we're on original
sound for musicians on all right one
more time noise suppression is disabled
okay I think we're ready to
initiate oh there we go mode initially
initiated
still didn't get it right still I turned
off all of it I don't know Zoom is doing
its thing I don't know it's too powerful
to power going power keep going we'll
get the audio from you
yeah initiating eye contact mode oh
not the eye contact mode that's that's
pretty
intense ENT double barrel
mode
that's a good that's a good one I like
that one we have a few more but uh those
we're still working on it you're the
best in the game man there's there's a
reason why you're blowing up at this I I
triy I I I was just going to say I love
how you cradle the balls I mean buns you
know you really oh whoa oh are you're a
are you're a genuine Gizzy
enjoyer maybe just for the show that's
fantastic I love a gzy
myself who does that come on who
doesn't um how come why don't you just
do it all day or do you find that the
returns are not they fade if you stay on
too long no I'll tell you the very
there's a very good reason why um it is
exhausting I can only go for maybe 45
minutes to an hour I'm if you watch the
streams I'm sweating I'm panting I am
and that's all real it's it's all real I
I need it ises your throat I'm putting
my all into it no believe okay so
believe it or not I'm actually still
recovering my voice it's not from the
glizzies I can do that all day that I
can do that all day I just I was just
screaming too much I got too many gifts
on Saturday and I almost lost my voice
oh man I've been down in the throat coat
um teas and the the cough drops I've
been there man it's tough so you're
doing like two a day basically whenever
you feel you have the energy to get back
in there I literally I wake up in the
morning maybe 7 a first thing I do go
live at 8:
a.m. and there's people up there ready
to ready to donate at 8:00 a.m. oh yeah
I mean I make I make like my days by I
mean I'm I'm good for the rest of the
day so like I wouldn't expect transient
Tick Tock live viewers to be so generous
I wouldn't either but you know what it
surprises me and it still surprises why
is somebody donating me a thousand gift
I don't know that's crazy dude maybe see
they see the Raw Talent they're patron
of the art
does he think that you going to gobble
his gzy perhaps with that high level of
donation I've gotten a lot of
DMs I don't maybe well could be
something to explore if your throat uh
doesn't recover although I don't know if
that will be good for your throat either
no yeah um here's Dex Dex stero man
them
dude literally not even credit you I
mean this is some cropped it
out cropped it out hate those
stero dude that's you guys
should be ashamed of yourself for that
do this a lot to out you why do they
like why do they do that like what how
does that benefit them I'll tell you why
they do it it REM it reduces their
liability they're less likely for him to
find it and see that they stole his
content yeah but then and when he does
find it it's so much worse it's such
scumbag it just it seems so stupid
I wonder if you could sue them for this
I'm super into that lately lawsuits
super into lawsuits like you could just
send him a threatening letter and
probably get a payout scumbags dude
everyone go tell or no I won't go down
that route yeah no no should I button
that
out yeah we're not going to say we're
not gonna we're not telling anyone to do
anything right Jason no no no no just go
to Jason's uh Tik Tok which is Jason do
reborn who's Jason right who's Jason
before the
birth uh well my I originally had uh
Jason the epic gamer it was just kind of
a little meme profile that got banned
why'd you get banned um I just I was
probably just arguing with like
conservatives in comment section or
something je dude they're ruthless went
down I don't know yeah let me watch your
recent but then we came back stronger
than ever Jason reborn yeah I like
that love your shirts man your shirt
game is so on point I'm telling you I
literally only that's all all I wear and
that's not a joke that's
not these are holy yo he's got the
receipts I swear to God it's all that I
wear and anybody who knows me can attest
to that I you will never see me on live
not in Teddy fresh dude that's so nice
thank you man I K really cool bro you're
not Jason reborn you're Jason
Bourn dude with a Gizzy
man thank you thank you Jesus
Congratulations by the way on 5 years oh
thank you so much man I appreciate that
let's I love you so much Z here your
most recent uh Tik Tok from a day
ago hi gizbot here my lives make some
people very triggered and angry tough it
ain't that serious y'all if my life ever
randomly goes down it's because I got
Mass reported and received a 10minute
kick it is only ever 10 minutes and we
will always come back because the
haters stay mad y'all I'm getting my bag
regard
stay mad bought out is it just people
who are hating on the whole NPC thing or
there's people that extra hate the Gizzy
angle I think there's people who extra
hate the Gizzy angle there's people who
hate the the teddy fresh they there's
people who just hate me there's there's
people who come in there it's like oh
Teddy that makes sense um damn but it's
it's there's just so many haters of all
different angles and varieties uh my
mods I tell them to be ruthless if
there's any sense of negativity just
instantly block we're not taking chances
like that there you go thought I'd share
how I eat Mike lizes with peanut butter
really Sam boil you ever getzy with
peanut butter did a Dono in the chat
saying peanut butter and Gizzy is their
preferred way think so yeah that's wrong
I don't believe them that's wrong well
man all I can say is we got to man all I
can say is
dexos you know
what dexos
you want to talk to my lawyer they'll
probably draft a good letter for you
sure you know what yes yes bro let's
send them a letter dude they can't do
that they stole your cut the credit
cropped it out the cutting of the the
cutting the cropping out of the
watermark shows a level of willful
infringement that's going to them
legally it's intent do we have your
email uh Dan does yeah I do all right
I'm going to hook I'm going to put you
in
touch let's go them in the ass dude
legally end the throat end the throat
which is yeah or well yeah I mean why
not so um anyway guys jason. reborn he
is the man he is the Gizzy
Legend I put the tag in the description
of the episode as well if you want to
check it out later Jason reborn thank
you man I'm really happy for you it's
such a cool Niche you found thank you
and I'm like I'm star strik being here
right now I'm such a massive fan I love
you so much um such a fan of the show
thank you bro I really appreciate that
so nice thank you oh yeah the
streaming but thank you we got to send
you a bunch of Teddy fresh so you can
continue to do your
ambassadorship let's go is there
anything you want specifically or like
do you want shorts or pants because
you're all shirted out yeah I'm all
shirted I'm all I have no pants I'm all
shirted you want some Teddy fresh pants
yes these all these tags these are all
shirts I don't know a single pair of
pants so what do you usually wear on
below the the waist long pants je just
like just like long pants like these are
some black just like black pants little
skinny so like a skinny little skinny
okay oh I could go I could go back here
you're fit though you know what I mean
if you've got it want it you exercise go
I used to I these Gizzy streams I might
need to hit some more cardio right well
you are getting your cardio in oh yeah
one way or the other are and I think um
ah people get angry when I ask this so I
won't okay good I'm adapting I'm
growing give it up
everybody give it up where do you where
abouts do you live in the country oh
actually
um hurricane Adalia has literally headed
straight for me I'm in Tallahasse
Florida right now oh you're going
to Gizzy through the hurricane yeah
we're going live through the hurricane
up guys let's go and I'm curious do your
friends and family know about this new
uh vertical that you're killing it in oh
my my my siblings do I I I don't know
about my parents they wouldn't
understand that probably right they
wouldn't understand I get hit up so like
oh my God I saw you on Twitter I saw you
on Tik Tok I love the gbot it's just
people I haven't heard from in years and
years and years but it's it's it's so
fun it's it's so amazing I really don't
mind the recognition at all I mean some
people would be afraid to be recognized
doing what I'm doing but I'm just having
fun guys funny it's comedy I wouldn't
it's not embarrassing at all it's funny
no no I mean the context that everyone
shared it as was just that it's
funny and like laughing with you too not
like the bad kind of
funny no all
right Jason reborn it is crushing it out
in
Tallahassee yeah that's right ready I
stay safe is this a is this one supposed
to be a big one is is this like a juicer
hurricane or I think so that's what I've
been hearing okay four categories I
don't even think there's like category
3's anymore it's All or Nothing they're
just fives or nothing yeah yesh all
right well stay safe all right Bud we'll
make it work we'll be in touch thank you
so much awesome thank you guys so much
lovece thank you Jason do
reborn let's get it let's get
it you know I feel like he could do that
for a while to come because the this
whole live streaming thing
is not going anywhere I don't think and
the Gizzy gobling is timeless I wonder
how long he's going to be able to do
that I hope he wins a streamy next year
for it dude best Tik Tok
live um speaking of stream I found the
unphotoshopped uh photo I knew we would
find that I knew we would find that than
oh really you've been looking this whole
time cam yeah it it took me a minute
hold on really this is like a loyalty
test between Dan and uh Cam's been
looking for this unedited photo for the
last hour here it is
guys there it is guys
wow what I don't know what the I'm
looking
at what's going on is that like an AI
hand wait his hand is so little
apparently the problem was that it was
photoshopped to make shed's hands look
bigger and your oh he's holding my thumb
yeah yeah dude he's got a little baby
that's epic shedy with the baby hand
dude his my thumb is so massive it's all
he can grab he's got such a baby an
idiot what a stupid
idiot you know I didn't think anything
could make me dislike J shett with those
eyes but his little stupid baby
well did you see the actual unedited
photo the second one yeah let me open it
up so here's the real
scoop on who has a bigger hand
so this is the unedited one right uh
wait I don't know wait what the is
written at the top Cameron uh that was
unedited that was just
there that was just you know how there's
Getty Images yeah that was gy Imes
watermark for some reason J sh please
hire me zoom out wait what yeah I don't
know wait and he's taller than me too
that's the unett one he has got a big
hand his face seems to be slenderized
and
stretched
jeez man really he's quite frightening
in this Photograph I gotta say looks
like he has
gig it looked like his voice sound like
this it's nice to finally meet you yeah
all right thank you for the unedited uh
versions Cameron anytime appreciate that
everybody's going to work for J shett
me
too J shed's hiring us
all I'm playing both sides so that I
always come out on top right I get
it you know what I mean it's a good bet
on Shetty it's always a good bet bet on
that's his when he runs for office
oh you can bet on you can bet on
as sure as sure as I'm
coming on through sure as
that's great so love Jason I was
GNA I was GNA huh I was going to ask if
if he's
single did you know I was going to ask
that yeah I thought you were going to
ask something else actually what did you
think I was going to ask I thought
you're going to ask if he was gay what
yeah why would I ask that because you
ask inappropriate questions about
people's sexuality sometimes I don't
just be like are you
gay well maybe G you gay no I have no
idea I was you asked what I thought you
were going to ask I thought that's what
you were going to ask Jesus man I was
just going to ask him if he's single
okay because I assumed I didn't go to
the audience too much but I assumed the
thirsting was happening cuz it always is
yeah he's he's single he's fit he's he's
got a great career wait we don't know if
he's single though cuz you didn't ask oh
right I didn't ask you didn't ask you
going be like all your life or will this
pass my shat don't
stank shat shat on my
yeah I'm trying to read some of these
suggestions but they're not they're not
really rolling off my tongue this
is so itchy I hate it all we got so much
good stuff to talk about actually that
we haven't got to we haven't gotten to
nothing today uh there's a new Jordan
Peterson is losing his goddamn
mind dude and and I love
it I think we need to make an anthology
of just Jordan Peterson is unhinged
lunatic part one all the way through
yeah so that when you guys have have
friends
family
co-workers who love Hib you could just
show them any one of these videos and
start breaking
through that being said you know what's
wild too is that there's two Jordan
Peterson things in the dock today
totally unrelated to each other he's so
crazy that I don't even know which one
you're referring to right now so this is
the one I saw last night and I was like
this man is nuts the is crazy dude
so medy Hassan is uh what's his what's
his what's his ethnic background oh he's
Middle Eastern Middle easn I think he's
Arab I'm not 100% he's definitely Brown
uhhuh so Jordan Peterson a white
like Catholic was bass goes so the Tweet
was tonight this brown Muslim is asking
the white conservative Community to do
the same get your house in order crack
down on the hate preachers condemn the
right of white supremacist
rightous ideology that seems like a
pretty
uncontroversial uh statement you'd think
so but he gets defensive for some reason
about them saying Chill on hate
preachers and white supremacy Jordan
took offense to that he said actually
you're not really Brown more like a
light tan just like quote white people
plus you're Caucasian by definition
buddy what Jesus there's so much going
on here and written like a Hu yes
there's so much going on here what does
he mean he's Caucasian okay so you let's
uh read the second tweet first it'll be
more helpful if you see his followup if
you scroll down okay there's a followup
and then and then we'll talk about it CU
it's D this guy wrote a whole
ass poem mhm about racism about
being a racist yeah have it your way you
boring Bloor
bloviator I don't really care if you
think you're green fine you're not
Caucasian you're black or Asian or
whatever you want to be just like all
you bloody
progressives for anyone who cares here's
what Wikipedia has to say what 19th
century classification of the peoples of
India okay is he Indian he is Indian
yeah were initially uh uncertain if the
dravidians and the salies were Co
coccoids that sounds like some
real Nazi yeah
yeah or a separate drav race but
by the 20th century anthropologists
predominantly declared dravidians to be
Caucasian the Caucasian race he's a
frequent page of his yeah so um why
don't is it in the doc already there the
link to that Wikipedia page I think it's
actually instructive to just click on
the link that Jordan himself shared and
Jordan a PhD PhD go ahead and click the
source that he cites and read the first
line this one the note just no just like
the beginning of the article just read
the Caucasian race is an obsolute racial
classification of humans based on now
proven theory of biological race now
disproven now disproven theory of
biological race why the Caucasian race
was historically regarded as a
biological taxin which depending on
which of the historical race
classifications was being used usually
included ancient and modern populations
from all over Europe West Asia
Central Asia South Asia North Africa and
Horn of Africa yeah what ises he LOL
this is some 19th C this is some 19th
century race science like where did he
even read
that well so if if you the the part that
he uh screenshotted and
shared um because that's further down in
the article but it's all of this is
being talked about in the context of
completely outmoded disproven racial
theories from almost two centuries go
why did he share that as as AA he quite
literally cherry-picked not even
cherry-picked just completely out of
contest yes like this was like this was
old when he was born like when Jordan
Peterson was born like this was outmoded
before he was even around let me let me
just give you an idea even like he just
remembers this from childhood like this
was disproven decades and decades ago
this page is actually interesting his
here's the history of the concept of
caucasians and this should inform you
the Caucasians as the origin of humanity
and the peak of
beauty yep seems seems a little biased
seems seems legit right every budding
Beauty and next it says the guton school
of History which I don't like the sound
of that at all when I saw that uml out I
knew this wasn't going to be good but
this isn't even close to 20th century
like this is not Nazi even this is
like so far beyond that that was 1780 it
said
why would he just for no reason be like
you're not you're you're not brown buddy
you're white just like me so watch your
back next time you ask white
supremacists to keep a lid on
it crazy crazy ass I could not
believe that he shared that Wikipedia
article like as if I mean you know a PhD
sharing a Wikipedia article as like
proof of anything is already like eh you
know but he didn't even read the thing
that he shared he did baby I guess he
doesn't care anymore I
guess what do you guys think of my long
hair so much work to keep out of your
face is that right
Zach uh when I'm like cooking or
something I'll like put it up in like
the top knot you know someone have a
crunchy for me crunchy a crunchy crunch
or something crunchy um I gave my only
crunchy to Dan yeah I'm rocking the
crunchy right now I'm afraid okay sorry
all good but sometimes like I'll wear
the hat you know right like I think I
might start becoming a hat guy yeah
you've been mentioning you look good
with Hats people when it says Rolex on
it yeah what's it and there's actually I
hope I'm not spoiling anything but
there's sort of a new persona oh yes hat
Zack kind of has a Persona here that he
debuted to us the not
Lou Lou's at home gol Golf Course Craig
this is Golf Course Craig Craig yeah you
can do better than Craig what's wrong
with my that's my name
pal okay Craig I'll see you at the green
all right I'll see you sure
will uh so actually but here's the main
Jordan Peterson part which was he made
this video about we talked about it on
Monday no today's Monday we talked about
it on last week sometime Friday that he
was ordered to pay
25,000 to the board of
psychologists in in uh Canada onario
yeah and take like a training course
because
he is psychotic and was talking badly
about current or former clients mhm
which is obviously a massive violation
of Ethics that was actually I think the
specific reason why it wasn't because
transphobic or yeah no they cited some
of that too long complaint yeah there
was a lot in there there was
specifically when he was on Joe Rogan he
was insinuating that people should just
off themselves if they have a problem
with climate change or with
uh uh overpopulation sorry and a few
other things that just isn't ethical if
you're a doctor to be saying so
just leave the organization then dummy
like you obviously because he's juicing
off of this like cuz he doesn't even
practice anym and hasn't since 2017 is
that right AB get some it I believe so
there was another complaint in 2018
which he agreed to straighten out and
he's still doing it the thing
is so yeah his framing it like it's
trying to control his speech is silly
he's just doing ethical violations which
he
knows or at least should
know that he's obligated to follow yeah
I mean with with get some with a lot of
uh professions like that like lawyers
for instance is the one example that you
brought up on Friday there's a bar
association there's like a Professional
Standards Association and that exists
for his line of work as well and he
violated a lot of fundamental principles
so he's getting the mildest push back by
the way not even threatened to kick out
just you have to chill on your so on
your Twitter account a little bit right
like and he he still has clinical
psychologist in his Twitter bio right
they keep saying I'm not even practicing
but you still represent them yes right
right so he put out a
38 minute video of him dressed up like
twoo faced from Batman uh raging about
it and Beauty so last time we didn't get
to go through it all but we've parsed
through it now and we can bring you our
favorite moments from Jordan Peterson's
meltdown OU literally become the Joker
literally
we'll see who cancels
who up yours woke
morus my former client was a real
they're like you can't say that up
ears W moralist oh there was nothing
sexual about my former client was a real
she slept
around and I sat there and judged her
the whole
time that's crazy it wasn't that much
crazier than
that what he did on road so let's see
Jordan shows how touch out of touch he
is multiple times in the video he misses
the entire point on purpose like we said
with J Shetty on man you're
good for uh for example uh as a doctor
he has responsibilities he's not
upholding for example he should not be
talking about someone's weight sorry not
beautiful you mean like posting a
picture of a of a uh large over what's
the right word oversized doesn't seem
right what do you I'm not sure what
you're going for like a BB dub SI big
beautiful just say that a big beautiful
woman okay sorry he posted a beautiful
the big beautiful woman swim
illustration with a BB dub and said
sorry not
beautiful so here he is Jordan crying
about the Gina
Jesus Jordan's crying about how the
college is trying to stop him from
having a political opinion which is
insane and obtuse and intentionally
misleading and I mean my God this man
has
no no shame he is so lost in the sauce
yeah look at him too he's just like
getting
redder his suits are getting crazy about
the situation in Canada I've been
thinking about it this morning as you
know the the the court that we appealed
the College of psychologists decision to
decided that the college
has it's within the college's purview to
stop me from having any political
opinions as far as I can tell dumy dummy
dumb stupid not what's happening
this is like basically equal
to it's actually even dumber I was going
to say people who get banned off Twitter
and then say free speech is dead right
actually even dumber because they're not
even they're not even deplatforming him
or trying to censor his speech they just
said you can't make these ethical
violations and still keep a license you
can you can re you can recant the
license you can step away from the or
right which again is why like I'm just
saying he's just juicing content off of
it because it's really I mean he's
transitioned out of that field of work
he's just a media personality he's Works
forist frankly yeah so you don't need
this license you're just using this to
get attention up yours Dan you Mor woke
moralist scum vagina and you know it's
kind of a an interesting parallel too to
his whole rise to fame which was him
freaking out over the bill in Canada and
totally misrepresenting what that bill
was in order to ride a wave to you know
that that was how he became he he knows
the power of intentionally
uh lying or mischaracterizing or
omitting I don't know yeah because I
didn't when I found out about the truth
about what that whole thing was is when
I started to turn on
himh although he's made it really easy
to hate him now like the past few years
right that was before he really started
become like a a Batman villain I'm
actually proud that we dropped him
before his villain Batman villain Arc
right you know what I mean we read we
saw it on the wall coming the decision
which I posted on Twitter and will post
in the description of this video starts
out by making a case for the fundamental
reality of freedom of speech for
Canadians in Canada and then says no
there in Canada oh I guess it maybe
it's not that
redundant but and that's always a bad
start when you're talking about freedom
of
speech but apparently the college has
the right to decide that I can be
re-educated
forcibly with the risk of my this man
really trying to make it sound like
Clockwork Orange where his eyes are
being held open with a toothpick while
they show them like naked trans people
insane you you my re-education
it's torture yes it's inhumane
yes if I have to re if I have to take a
ethics course humanity is over it's Doom
that's aitz it's aitz it's
worse my license essentially because I
made political statements that the
members of the college don't agree with
and those ex those
those um opinions I doubt he ever
actually says what happened he only
speaks in vague like
re-education freedom of
speech for the most part yeah he's just
intentional misleading anytime it gets
into
specifics he never says what the ethic
violation was does he ever say ethic
violation um I think he he focuses in a
lot on The Joe Rogan
podcast um because that one I feel like
feels like he needs to comment on it
like he's even encouraging his daughter
to like bring up like oh you had a few
more points you wanted to bring up that
was one of them this is going back in
time
but Bill c16 did not in fact making you
using the wrong pronouns in illegal
which is what he claimed his rise to
fame it's incredible that so many people
rode this wave with him Joe Rogan being
one of them and nobody ever actually was
like even tried to like verify what he
said which is like a super outrageous
thing so if you say something so strong
and outrageous like in Canada it's now
illegal to you not use someone's
preferred
pronoun that begs some
investigation yeah uh and to be fair I
think there probably were people
sounding the alarm on that at the time
but um and we have to acknowledge that
we were part of that I mean we had him
on our show and I didn't talked to him
about that stuff but yeah yeah I mean
but it came up because we we did talk to
him he had those confrontations with the
reporters around that time and we you
know we did talk about some of his
controversy that interview was really
bad to be honest I went back and watched
it recently did you really I haven't
seen it in years it it was she was so
out of pocket yeah just bad but anyway
uh they said rather repeated Andor
intentional misgendering could already
constitute harassment pursuant to Human
Rights and employment law which only
occurs a few areas under Federal
jurisdictions such as Banking and air
travel is repeated assertion that b Bill
66 bill c16 created this offense despite
being corrected borders on bad faith B
yeah I think it's more I think it's it's
it's jumped the Border politely
worded Jordan claims that one of the
reasons he got the complaint is because
he went after climate apocalyptic
fear-mongering holy
uh this is not the case the
complaint literally claims he insinuated
people
should uh un alive themselves as one of
the ethic violations which I can I mean
if you're a clinical
therapist probably I can see why I would
be against ethics to tell people to kill
themselves that's like kind kind of like
the the Baseline yeah well I can see him
doing like a oneone with somebody well
have you considered killing yourself
Jesus it's a lot easier than dealing
with your
problems it's an easy Escape just do it
just real quick I was just going through
because I I have Jordan Peterson pretty
much saying everything I have more
soundbits of him than anybody anything
in this board really he's the number one
almost 200 Jordan holy
whoa that's more than I would have ever
guessed yeah keeps giving too every
every
week it reads here's what it literally
said in the
complaint a further complaint about Dr
Peterson's uh January 2nd tweet in which
Dr Peterson responded to an indiv
individual who expressed concern about
overpopulation by stating you are free
to leave at any
point the further complaint provided a
link to a 2018 GQ interview in which Dr
Peterson made a similar comment about
unal
living it's right there in the
complaint which I'll leave that I'm sure
his lawyer read uh very carefully I'll
leave and him uh presumably too as a
learned man PhD what a dumbass so here
he is no it's the climate change AC of
is M we're coming for you my objection
on Joe Ro Rogan to The Climate
apocalyptic fear mongering that idiot
tyrants are foisting on the general
population now apparently that makes me
unprofessional and a uh disgrace to that
was not I don't was that mentioned in
the
complaint that just
like let me double check it I have it
linked here you know what I mean I just
I love that all of a sudden Jordan's
like a climate skeptic just for no
reason like this man has zero
credentials and now he's just getting
involved in all the right-wing
griffs why not you got to tow the party
line right uh I'm looking at the uh uh
what do you call it the Judgment that he
shared and I'm just contrl F climate
zero Z out to zero why would they uh
environment um uh global warming no why
would they so stupid you're lying you're
just lying
dude to the profession such that I am
now going to be required that college
can go ahead with this to put me into a
re-education program with okay he's
making it sound like 1984 it's just like
a you got to brush up on your ethic it's
like HR class yeah it's like it's like
an annoying HR afternoon Reed he's
making it sound like you know in a
torture room where they try to supplant
your thoughts with new ones 1984 style
it's
not in reality it's like a a room with
Michael
Scott and like a PowerPoint about don't
tell your clients to kill themselves
step
one I see you're trying to re-educate
me I'll tell them whatever I want damn
it bucko bucko woke
moralist called social media experts and
that's also by the way a profession that
does not exist until I learn my
what mandatory this man is non-stop
psychotic he said social media experts
don't exist
precisely what why education program
their socalled social media experts and
that's also by the way a profession that
does not exist why that's like totally a
job bro I mean it's his job I mean all
he does the daily wire the daily wire is
probably full of yeah he's
self-employed online always yeah like
that's I think he would consider himself
more of a uh commentator than a oh yes
online a social media expert that's what
love you just think that somebody that
spends that much time on social media
would understand that there are people
that make a profession out of
specializing you mean like biggest and
most important like the very fabric of
our society right as professionals about
it doesn't make any sense I'm going to
see how many times he's tweeted or
retweeted things today yeah he dedicates
time experts in every field it doesn't
make any sense like what this man says
he's an expert I use Twitter 20 hours a
day bucko I think I know a thing or two
yeah the
until I learn my lesson whatever
that is regardless of how much time that
takes by their judgment or they can take
my license away I think and so the the
court says well of course you have
freedom of speech Dr Peterson but
because you're a
professional you're bound by your
Professional Organization and apparently
they're not bound even though they're a
government organization fundamentally
apparently they're not bound by that
fundamental constitutional axom he he's
so close to getting it he was right
there just because I'm bound to a code
of eth by my
profession well what about them what
code of conduct are they bound
to what is what
mean what does code mean
anyway and so that shows you all you
Canadians who are listening and everyone
outside of the country who might be the
least bit interested in Canada that
shows you exactly what our bloody
Constitution is worth and if Canadians
are so daff that they don't think that
that's a I mean
he's so obtuse
41 41 times today this man's tweeted
twet tweeted or retweeted something holy
that is that is like unwell he is
unwell I mean we know that but golly and
nobody in his life is able to stop him
everyone well this vulture
psychopath daughter loves it because
she's built a career off of
exploiting female dragon energy trying
to kill her own father utter
carelessness that's one of the reasons
he's so worried about losing his title
because now if he loses his title how
long until people start to look at him
like okay maybe he is just some
crazy guy right right yeah I mean it
gives him an erir of credibility but
that's the issue right is that he's
using it as a CR exactly to create an ER
of credibility it delegitimizes the
field yes that's why they care and again
the Constitution's got nothing to do
with it because it's not you can go say
whatever the you
want just don't do it with us or in or
while representing yourself as in the
capacity of being a
professional I I got to say I mean from
my perspective that that board is
uh is right on man good for them I
respect them more problem well they're
going to figure it out over the next 15
years because there's
absolutely no excuse for this so This
section by the way is called how how Dr
Peterson is doing not
well I've tweeted 42 times
today I'm out of
benzos
um oh where did he mention the climate
thing I clicked that he didn't we I
guess he briefly mentioned it yeah he
did
yeah uh further complaint yada yada
Jordan Peterson complains it's not
fair the psychology organization is not
bound by regulations I think I just read
that or listen to that part
mhm Jordan says he's not wrong and then
continues on to threaten the cour the
courts and colleges cool axum and so
that shows you all you Canadians who are
listening and everyone outside of the
country who might be the least bit
interested in Canada that shows you
exactly what our bloody Constitution is
worth although not much further and if
Canadians are so daff that they don't
think that that's a problem well they're
going to figure it out over the next 15
years because there's
absolutely no excuse for this so that's
what I'm thinking now there's part of me
that's
thinking well look
Peterson the col psychologists is after
you you've taken it to court now the
judges have decided that you're wrong
maybe you're wrong
yes the whole world all the different
layers of of the system have said I'm
wrong
maybe I am wrong let's hear
out am I out of
touch no it's the children who are
wrong it's even worse than that it's
like the teach the children the teachers
the
organization and I think well I
expressed political sentiment and I'm
actually informed and so for the life of
I'm really informed for example did
anyone read that Wikipedia article about
the Caucasian race remember when he uh
tweeted a porno of the Chinese dick
sucking Factory yes that was so SI
that's my favorite a psycho well
informed
here me I can't see how I'm wrong that
happened that happened he tweeted a
video of like a fetish video of like 20
dudes getting milked by a machine and he
was like my God China is crazy and it
was like some uh was in England it was
England at some yeah it Legend
dude I'm
informed I think I have a responsibility
to say what I think and I think many
people agree with that and I think the
fundamental consequence of that around
the world has been massively beneficial
to people so I think I think number one
what the hell and number two bring it on
what hell wow that's a good plan of
action
step one what the
hell step two bring it
on step
three take some
Xanax step
four have a
nap see what happens cuz I will make
absolutely every bit of this public in a
way that the
college and the courts can hardly even
imagine
so what a dick away we go so that's how
I'm doing that's how you're doing okay
but
good no did you were you listening
Michaela did you just zone out the whole
time it looked like she did kind of yeah
but good you know I mean I didn't look
the court decision was worse than I
thought it would be I was already
pessimistic I figured the court
would take the coward's way out and
basically upgrade the college for
procedural inadequacy because one of the
things shut
up
dummy uh let's see here Jordan says what
rules he does that again oh yeah what
rules what rules yeah yeah perfect it's
a great thing to highlight you know it's
it's like well you have this fundamental
right but well but what what rules
there's what there's a rule a there's a
rule rules I don't believe in rules the
College of psychologists has that I
can't criticize Justin Trudeau on
Twitter that's I don't think that was
one of the things you told is that you
said the kill yourself thing pretty
explicitely I searched Justin Trudeau in
the complaint I never seen that once
dude he's such a
liar what the hell
man cuz if he said what he was really
being uh reprimanded for everyone would
be like oh yeah you definitely shouldn't
do that like you're % in the wrong
right they said you've been telling
people to kill
themselves as a clinical psychologist
that's a rule is it and if
someone anywhere in the world complains
about the fact that I've criticized
Justin Trudeau let's say that all of a
sudden that's a rule even though it
wasn't a rule and bro you're like I
don't even know he's just rambling he's
making up he does talk about
another politician Katherine mckenny who
he calls a thing that's in the complaint
a thing a thing he call he refers to her
as a thing is that a is she like uh
trans or something binary or trans yeah
I I'm I think that's probably a safe
guess I would think so too and I would
assume that would be like a super
transphobic yeah
comment uh there's a donation from uh
somebody says Canada doesn't have the
same freedom of speech as the US does
our constitution never explicitly States
freedom of speech only thought belief
and expression I mean I'm not familiar
enough with like the Canadian Charter to
know what the Nuance of that is but I
mean regardless like here in the United
States it's like there are we we have
freedom of speech in the Bill of Rights
but there are still reasonable limits on
the bar right the bar you have no right
to control what I write you have no
right I mean it's nonsense mckenny the
person he called a thing is queer and
the first non-male openly LGBT person to
serve on Ottawa city council that's
really up we called it they are
non-binary and use they them pronouns
well yeah you're really I mean why why
why do that right also this was
mentioned
uh Dr Peterson appeared to be
engaging in degrading comments about a
former client and making demeaning jokes
F on The Joe Rogan Experience it can
expressed concern that by referring to
Elliot paage as her and by their former
name and by calling Katherine mckenny an
appalling self-righteous moralizing
thing that he might uh be sending the
wrong
message I don't get it
man he just outright lying just a
propagandist at this point like straight
up so if the college wants to re-educate
me they're more than welcome to try I
love when he gets angry but if they
think they're going to do it in
secret they've got another think coming
dude why you are you talking
about again he he's he's trying so hard
to conjure in people's mind a
white operating room right from
1984 where they're you know tortur in
him uh brainwashing him you know what I
mean
yep there's no se like this is all this
was big news big news we're looking at
like all of the court filings you could
just look them up that's why he need
Title to make any of the secret yeah
that's why he needs the title because
without it he's just this dude in this
crazy suit with his own signature on the
lapel yeah I I keep my name here cuz I
frequently forget the Xanax affect my my
short-term memory it's a reminder I look
in the morning and I oh well it's me
it's Geor it says Peterson that's me
calms me down who is that
man I don't recognize myself I'm red
turned so
red I was never this red I was a white
man and now I'm a red
man
every morning I jump scare
myself some have even called me a tan
man by golly
dimly but that's still Caucasian so
don't even try me
bucko
here but then I see my name on my lapel
and it brings me great comfort to know
my own
name median and then I go
to
work where I look in the mirror again
and see my name and it brings me great
comfort because I'm lost and
confused
women I may have found the part of the
complaint uh why he's referring to
climate change although it's not
directly climate change but it is he did
make a comment that was uh related to uh
pollution
go ahead um that was specifically
singled out would you like to hear what
he said love to this was on Jordan or on
the Joe Rogan show as well uh speaking
about air pollution and child deaths Dr
Peterson said it's just poor children
and the world has too many people on it
anyway whoa he said that that's a quote
he he does bring that part up he brings
that part up and he's like uh they use
that which was clearly a joke against me
that's like the only specific pull I
want to see him saying that let me see
I've got to yeah that's crazy are still
not a great joke if you're a you know
are Rogan's old episode still on YouTube
or do they pull all that down when
they went to Spotify I think it's all
down H it might be kind of hard to find
then cuz it's only Joe Rogan's UPS
they're still up the the old Joe Rogan
episodes I wasn't sure if they pulled
him when he but this was a switch I one
I
think let's see it was in
uh oh you're right oh this was more
recent than I thought I thought yeah oh
this is another appearance I see yeah it
was in January of 2022 so yeah it's on
Spotify it's probably not going to be on
YouTube rip I'd love to go through the
complaint and just actually list all the
stuff that they are repre
repre mening him forh cuz they all are
bangers poor children are a
joke and I think it's important to note
that if he wants to keep his license all
he has to do is just take the course and
it could all go away but he refus want
me to take princip they want me to take
an online course with multiple choice
answers takes approximately 15 minutes
won't do
it poor kids man if a if a poor child
dies in Uganda do you even
notice
no we need Les mouths to feed damn it
I've never done anything let them eat
each other they're so damn
[Music]
hungry they're like um that's a little
insensitive for a psychologist to be
saying I'll kill you first of all that's
a hell of a way to put it a't
it this is interesting too Peterson
identified himself on Twitter as a
clinical psychologist in 2022 this
appears to be changed from 2020 when
although a member of the college at the
time he stated that he opted not to
advertise this title on his Twitter that
was a good call should have stuck with
that so he later went out of his way
to put that into his bio and present
himself more openly and I can see then
why they would be like yeah let's not do
that
right fair play I I like when he gets
angry though
man he's really so scary huh well wow
with that it was nice talking to you
have fun at the presidential debate
tonight I like your suit I like how
she's just like I'm wrapping it up all
right I'm getting flashbacks to my
childhood angry Jordan is not it's too
much for
me oh thank you isn't it
ridiculous yeah it's good you stand out
I like it very SLE yeah yeah yeah well I
thought I'd blend in with the crowd
tonight you know you know the Americans
they're very theatrical right this
everything Americans do is theatrical
theatric you're the most
theatrical man nobody else is dressed
like that no he's a piece of theater
walking he's a theater girl he's a
theater girl he's the worst type of
theater girl right he's one of the ones
that give us a bad rep not us girls we
need to disbar him from
theater that's the title he needs to get
rid ofial debate it's theater of the
best sort and
I'm down here to have an adventure you
know and
so and it's what I should be
concentrating on look at this am my
writing you know it's Fire and Ice looks
like he's showing that he has he's bomb
strapped through his
chest it's
funny Fire and Ice you know freak just
like the mind my
mind sometimes it's fire and sometimes
it's
ice it's like my
coffee sometimes it's hot sometimes it's
cold that's
right sometimes it's like the corpses of
dead Ugandan
children sometimes it's
hot and other times it's
cold there's Jordan for you guys
psychotic
freak
dude it's crazy also how like this man
is clearly unwell and the daily wire is
just straight up so happy to just
capitalize on this very unwell man and
they love it too they I'm sure they're
just right in the way man but you know
behind the scenes bench Piro and his
partner Jeremy whatever are like he's he
is crazy I mean how could you
not I don't know but yeah I mean they
also employ Matt Walsh who right is
pedophile dude so Jordan Peterson has a
Twitter suit with a Tie featuring Elon
musk's
head oh God how much you spend on that
cuz it's not called Twitter
anymore should tell you about my suit
first oh my God maybe don't that is
actually the worst tie ever
made and uh this is a Twitter suit in
the here there's a bunch of comments
from Twitter about another suit this
company made for me this company is
gfg and they came to me a couple of
months ago and asked me if I wanted them
to make me some suits is this part of
your campaign to be taken more seriously
or I'm confused about the intention here
one for each of the rules from 12 rules
for life and uh they sent a little deck
of creative ideas and they were very
creative and so I thought well sure why
not and so I hope you're editing that
fire and ice one to have C4 on
them you're already on it right I I'll
get on it right now can that be
perceived as us like threatening him I
don't think so it's just a little like I
don't know you think I know the joke is
that he's doing it but if somebody clips
that out of context if you're if you're
worried then we'll skip it I just maybe
we can have I have the same exact
thought don't get me wrong but I just
feel like throwing that up on screen
might butt Us in the ass all right what
else Oliver Anthony updates are pretty
interesting the rich man North or
Richman he's already cancelled he went
woke he went woke folks he went woke so
um or maybe he always was woke this is
very very interesting stuff we talked
about this a bit last week and how this
guy's lyrics was just about how he hates
fat people and Welfare Queens tour buses
and it's pretty natural conclusion that
he's a
conservative but he says
no uh-uh uh-uh you don't want tour buses
what do you want just people to start
appreciating each other for human beings
and look other than the fatties of
course nobody wants
them goddamn fudge rounds non political
difference why am I doing Jordan still
and ideologies and a lot of the things
that I see corporate media and education
doing which is making everyone identify
each other's differences and not their
similarities I want people to appreciate
each other and appreciate each other's
struggles and hopefully uh you know
hopefully just find the energy that was
in this song and and manifest it in and
people's own personal I'm so confused
about his whole shtick because his song
was very clearly like fat people ain't
got no reason and people who are in
welfare are the
problem kind of I don't know I think
that I think that there are a lot more
people that have
that kind of incoherent worldview than
you may realize it's just uh cuz
remember I mean the rest of the
song uh you like the first like verse
you weren't really taking issue with and
then suddenly kind of veers off I mean
people's political beliefs are
not are usually not coherent in my
opinion and well if just I know I just
not even a a political thing it's just
like want all people to get along other
than the fatties you understand all
people he actually uh did we I I don't
think he had um issued his clarification
yet uh would you like to read this part
that I just highlight let me finish this
vid okay lives just just trying to find
similarities with each other instead of
division that's that's really all I want
I I mean I don't see our country lasting
more than another generation the way
we're headed we've got to we've got to
go back to the of what made this country
great in the first place which was our
sense of community and our I mean we are
the Melting Pot of the world and that
that's what makes us strong as our
diversity and we need oh he did not just
say that our diversity makes us strong
we are the Melting Pot of the world
diversity makes us strong which kind of
funny cuz I feel like when I was a kid
that was just taken for granted or I
mean like that was just obvious because
you were getting your head filled with
that liberal propaganda in
California I mean it it's literally
called The Melting Pot of the world
that's a real thing to learn to harness
that and appreciate it and not use it as
a political tool to keep everyone
separate from each other you know so as
you can imagine the conservatives were
not happy about him saying that he likes
diversity of course that's a horrible
horrible claim and shame on him uh
where's the Tweet where he gets called
out for it uh by who cuz he got I mean
there was a bunch which one are you
referring to well where's where are
they uh
I
don't there was one that went uh Mega
viral which was the first time I saw it
about basically him saying he's a fan of
diversity but here he is now uh where he
realized that I'm might have up
with this whole thing the one thing that
has bothered
me is seeing people wrap politics up
into
this uh
I'm disappointed to
see like it's aggravating seeing people
on conservative news try to identify
with me like I'm one of
them it's aggravating seeing certain
musicians and politicians act like we're
buddies and and act like we're fighting
the same struggle here like that we're
trying to present the same
message
uh you know I've had a lot of people
reach out to me and I tried to be polite
to everybody and um I've talked to
hundreds of people the last two weeks it
seems like certain people want to just
ride the attention of this song to maybe
make them their own selves relevant and
that's aggravating as hell the other
thing that I find aggravating is
uh well you know like it was funny
seeing my song in the it was fun it was
funny seeing it at the presidential
debate cuz it's like I wrote that song
about those people you know so for them
to have to sit there and listen to that
uh that cracks me
up uh but it was funny kind of seeing
the response to it like that song has
nothing to do with Joe Biden you know
it's a lot than Joe Biden
um that song is written about the people
on on that stage and a lot more too not
just them but but definitely
them uh I find I think think it's nice
to hear this but I do I am curious about
what he thought was going to happen when
he teamed up with a like Republican
operative Pro provocator propagandist to
produce this I you know we talked at the
time there were a lot of people putting
forward that you know the industry plant
thing and everything and that he might
be phony as time has gone on I I think
that this guy really is just a simple
man who lives by himself in a rural area
and they kind of he got exploited like
he got used I I don't think he was
necessarily in on the grift so he's the
real deal I mean he
claims that he was offered giant record
deals after all of this he he claimed he
was offered an $8 million record deal
and he refused it cuz he didn't really
want I I don't believe him I don't know
if I
uh I don't buy that he definitely had to
have gotten a couple offers Maybe given
him 8 million one hit song but like some
something I guess no what I fig at least
something for a record deal it wasn't
just the one song it was like yeah but
nobody's putting out that kind of money
after one hit song it's just not
happening look here's the deal here's
the deal here's the deal
Jack um AF H I don't know where's the
Tweet uh Dan I saw do you remember what
the tweet it had like 50,000 plus likes
what what did it say
remember it's somewhat similar to this
one it was very uh neutral but all the
responses were like
psycho I'll see if I can find it but
isn't there like all the typical
right-wing guys talking about him
on Twitter now too no all of the big
personalities don't because they look
like idiots um it's it's the rank and
file that have turned on him you know
what I mean you're not going to see Matt
Walsh uh who was one of his biggest
promo
like oh I was wrong about this guy no
they'll just move
on here is uh Oliver saying he received
an $8
million record deal yeah third paragraph
there where he talks about it people in
the music industry gave me blank stairs
when I brushed off $8 million I don't
want six tour buses five tractor trailer
you don't want five tractor
brother and a jet I don't want to play
stadium shows I don't want to being in
the spotlight I wrote the music I wrote
Because I was suffering with mental
health and depression these songs have
connected with millions of people on
such a deep level because they're being
sung by someone feeling the words in the
very moment they were being sung no
editing no agent no just some
idiot with this guitar style of music we
should have never gotten away from in
the first place
um kind of
gepy what we can only like I don't mind
like bluegrass music
but we we that's all we can listen to um
that's it
but or does he just mean heartfelt music
so so what exactly was his reason for
turning down 8 million just cuz I don't
want money like what was his reason he
just I don't want none of your money I
think he just he doesn't want any part
of that City Slicker life I do not
believe
him I don't want nothing to do with them
City Slickers oh come on here uh uh
propagandist with your nice cameras and
perfect audio setup come out here in
my my barn out here in the little the
greens ain't no reception nothing
perfect audio I tell you what
[Music]
Bo I don't want no
money someone offered me 8 million I
said I don't want no money
who wants me to take their money I just
want
to did here on my
porch mhm sip that sweet te check this
out that's so vile they go he
got the call and then straight Nazi
he's a Jew he must be a
Jew he's like the most not Jewish
looking person for
real let's
see in the same post he talked about
himself quite a bit from 2014 until a
few days ago I worked in
sales in the industrial manufacturing
world yeah I'm sure he I'm sure he's
would love to keep doing that nine hours
a day for the rest of his life my job
has taken me all over Virginia and into
the Carolinas getting to know tens of
thousands of bluec workers on job sites
and
factories people are so damn tired of
being neglected divided and
manipulated in 2019
I paid 97,000 for the property and I
still owe about 60 on
it I'm living in a 27 ft camper with a
tarp on the roof that got Craigslist for
750 I don't want no
money all I want here is my
truck some sweet
Tay and the company of a nice sheep keep
your hands off my
car is it a do they sheep or is
that like is that a a middle of nowhere
thing what do they do out there what
animals do they I don't think they
animals you sure yeah I'm pretty
sure J RH n BR are you sure I think they
animals I'm pretty sure he would say you
kids so you know huh you're Coastal
Elite eat Hollywood did I kids just
to play devil's advocate for a second
all right well who you then
bucko mhm you tell me you live out there
middle nowhere with one damn sheep who
just happen to be a
female and I'll tell you I seen sheep in
my day but I ain't never seen one look
that
good got her all dressed up with a
[Music]
bow man is sick
um
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway that's about
it so I guess he's not a
uh this is like the worst outcome for
him cuz now that he's like I'm not a
conservative and I like diversity
now everybody's abandoned
him you know yeah no radical centrism
for
you here we go um yeah I mean I
don't know 420 how long we' been going
bro let's go dude we got to go
uh we've been going for 3 hours and 10
minutes
wait why are people so
angry the way you were talking about
that guy was a little out of touch not
going to lie like what not all people
from rural areas sheep it's pretty
offensive yeah I know they don't all
sheep you were you were asking why
people I mean everybody some do though
I'm sure some
do just like not everybody in Hollywood
kids but some do though yeah I
agree with that right I agree with
that I mean if you live in
rural if you live in rural
town and you know you ain't the
Sheep well then that's good and I ain't
talking about you
brother I mean fair enough I'm talking
about
you you're one of the good ones no see
that sounds kind of weird too if you I
think if someone if someone's going to
an animal they'll do it in whatever
state right yeah right right there's
just more privacy out there yeah more
privacy more remote yeah no for real
what what did I say just tell me out of
touch are these all are are the
southerners
upset
nah I just see weed chat now okay well
we chat's a good change I'm for Virginia
so yeah this guy says I'm from rural
Virginia did not find it offensive I
mean yeah if you're not sheep
then you shouldn't have be offended by
it fair enough like genuinely I see what
you also I don't think this guy
sheep either I think you know I I don't
know how to feel about him I I'm I'm
confused now I you know taking it all in
like I said before I think this guy is
actually representative of what a lot of
people in this country are which are
totally disenfranchise not kind of
disengage from politics they think both
parties are the same they don't really
have strong beliefs they more just have
Grievances and they see how up
things are which if we take away the the
uh fudge round line in his song I mean
and well and the there was two fat fat
did he come back to the fat thing and
there was a welfare thing I thought that
was part of it it he was saying people
are buying fudge rounds with their
welfare and getting there was the one
about the 350 and 53 if you fit 350 and
53 don't come near
me pull pull up the lyrics he wasn't
racist right he said no no there was R
racist he doesn't like fat people it
just was like welfare and fat people I
mean that's not the biggest offense
well here it
is taxes not to pay for your BS drown
yeah see it's the same line my taxes
shouldn't pay for your fud rounds so if
you're a little Porky pie I don't want
to be feeding you no round
pies now here this was the part I was
saying earlier this was his um sort of
explaining away the fud round line he
said our government this is him talking
specifically about the fudge round okay
our government likes to throw money at
problems without conceptualizing real
solutions that connect to the
individuals involved the lyrics contrast
that some are left without any and
others are only left with the option of
living on junk food meanwhile our
farming industry has been corporatized
and sold out food is entirely too
expensive especially in a nation with
abundant Farmland in politics it's all
about keeping people who are dependent
dependent that is such the man
said it played again Zach yeah I I nice
try but I mean that's a nice sentiment
but
milk the
OB OB be are milking welfare yeah I know
you're
right and you know what's funny pause it
again he go maybe it could be an analogy
obese being like the people who have
plentiful and I but then he goes no but
if you're 53 and you weigh 300 lb I'm
talking about you fat like he removes
all and
300b taxes not to pay for your bags the
analogy is gone he he he's like no no no
no I'm talking about fat people and this
and this goes back to what I said before
about just I don't
know people's ideological beliefs you
know don't always make sense they're not
always
coherent well you know I'm a man of the
people even if I don't understand what
it's like to live in some kind of you
know Southern kind of
world Midwestern light Southern light
he's from Virginia so good old virgin
like to come down to the barn on
weekends do our Pig
Carina I won me one of them last
month come on now
piggy I'm just being silly you guys come
on seriously I'm a man of the people you
guys know
that just being silly Don't Call Him a
fat pig you can't but if I did say
something out of line I do want to
apolog
oliz I don't think it was any specific
thing it's just you know you've heard
this criticism before it's just may
maybe we do need to um appeal more to
the uh no just go I feel like you would
benefit from going to the South let's
just put it that way and like actually
meeting people I know you project you
project the stereotypical Californian
who doesn't know anybody from the south
a joke I know it's a joke just try try
a goat before you talk that's
right don't knock it until you try it
bro don't knock it until you try it bro
when in Rome right I know that everybody
there is not like the dumb character
they're normalized people I know that
yeah I don't need to go there but I will
go there you know what I mean no and I I
I I do know that you are just joking but
I'm talking about how it comes if you're
a fan who maybe lives in the rural South
somewhere and episode after episode
you're coming off saying things like
that I I could see why people would get
annoyed okay I thought it was funny and
if you watch
show all right everybody everybody's got
a right to have feel you got some type
of feeling that's fine Brother let's
talk about it I got to give you a shout
out you kept the wig on this whole time
man thank you brother looking good too I
love my Long beautiful lcks of ha
boy uh let's see well I guess we have to
take a group trip to Louisiana some kind
of Virginia I could take you guys to
where I went to school in R Ohio
amishtown see there you go I have a I
got a southerner right here that is not
in the
South the South Midwest what state was
that sweetheart Ohio
Ohio we know about them good old
southern folk in Ohio they good people
got one right here yeah where is
our our Southerner our Souther she
walked out she was so mad I'm just
kidding don't please don't think that I
was serious when I said that okay wait I
got a serious comment finally what uh
they say Ethan you sound out of touch
and totally unaware how the South
actually operates okay s
sha we know you guys don't animals
right yeah I don't know that clear like
I don't actually well that's why I asked
I said do they animals there and
then Dan clarified we fact checked it
life fact checking ladies and Gent
fact
checking yeah but that's true I I've
never been to any of these countries you
know what I mean you have to ask Sam
when she comes back s's a good old
sweetheart met her at a Parabellum ball
Parabellum what do you call that
Plantation ball ant antum I met her at
an antab Bellum ball that's up
that's a joke that was what um
the Bachelorette right yeah oops well
you know we were thinking about going to
um Montana for a good old and location I
mean that's extremely rural I think it's
the most rural State uh except for maybe
Wyoming but is definitely not the South
either it's pretty close it's the you
all been to Montana it's a good old
southern yeah I see what it's rural what
does it care where it is I like these
rural folk man they good people um they
don't know much but they good people do
you want to see the most redneck thing I
ever went to when I was in uh when I
lived in Georgia yes hold on this you'll
get it real quick out of this even you
might have to mute it because I think
there might be AUD um copyright audio
bit though visuals speak for themselves
is it like
a yo see this looks fun this was sick I
can't see
anything what oh you want me to pull it
up I mean he said it in the Discord do
you want me to see
it green Dixie speed
because yeah yeah this is the Dixie
Speedway so they can watch it right now
oh God they're racing with boats
waterless boat race the objective is
that everyone has to hit the
uh the boats off the back of each
other's cars you know what that's so
cool actually way better a big
event for the squid billies Premiere
party and uh this is where it was some
of y'all you guys are right I do not
understand Southerners wait this is
awesome though this is like a this is
like a Mario Kart game you know
literally Mario Kart the goal is to
dislocate the boat yeah get the boats
off of the other cars and try and crash
the other cars as you do too a lot of
carage is great I want to go to a
monster truck show so bad they have
those here we need to go I've gone to
multiple BR I've never been I have to go
nothing better than a Bud Light in my
hand or a monster truck in front of
me like H dog in my other hand see and
my Miss is next to me see NASCAR stuff
seems boring to me but I would def
definitely go to this this looks awesome
askar is boring as fck is this like a
real League or is this just like a goof
they do every once in a while once in a
while yeah well it is I guess like a
real thing in that area but I mean this
is real Ingenuity I mean this this is
this is always spinning out a lot of uh
dip in the audience a lot of people's
lip I think it's cool that like they all
came together yeah people go crazy for
it I was going crazy for it exting don't
have any Trail I love Georgia so that
car his is gone why isn't he pulling out
yeah maybe there's like a turnoff area
that he has to get to or something not
sure I don't know yeah that guy didn't
have a damn boat or maybe it's just
there he goes he pulled over okay there
you go Infowars oh my God Y what the
an infow Wars van I've been right
we were trying to I'm sorry Alex Jones
is
from there it is that's why he's just
driving around I'm telling y'all try to
disprove Me by sending me damn Wars van
TR to bring out the whole ocean Alex
Jones that is very funny he's our
man so funny happened that did not work
out well this one dude being a fan of
infow Wars okay so some of them are like
that then well we were talking earlier
about we were talking about
sheep earlier not are they right-wing
psychos yeah there's definitely
rightwing psychos there's a nut on Santa
Monica Pier that always plays infow Wars
outside of
we got plenty we got plenty here in La
too that's true maybe not the cheap you
guys got to admit it's funny there's an
infowar van there it's hilarious it's
amazing don't try to downplay that I'm
not trying to downplay it but yes to all
my S to all my Rural and Southern uh
foot soldiers out there I'm a man of the
people I love all people I'm a man of
the working people and I love fatties I
love me a
fatty you eat your fudge rounds brother
it's seesters here here's a Dono you
like
days uh as a royal Midwest Southerner
from the north I feel Ethan should give
a
so and
[Music]
solidarity o that's
good no legit though I shouldn't
alienate our our allies to the to the
east and that's the thing is like
anybody who watches this show that's
from the rural South they they are in
hostile territory we should be
supporting them that's true we need to
court them we need to we need to be more
inclusive shut up well I need to have a
shtick diversity is our strength just
like Anthony
said wait I need I need a Californian
stick hi
there let me think do you take credit
card hi there hi there is there gluten
in there
can you tell me does this Taco come with
a vegan option do you per chance have a
vegan option here
sir what else is there good um what else
do we what else do we do oh does this
coffee have dairy in it I need oat
milk hello I need oat milk in my coffee
this your new NPC character for I don't
know I'm trying to figure it out
I need
oat I like that californ just speaks
really properly for some reason I'm
trying to figure it out would it the
California would just be a what do you
call it uh like d SE valley girl yeah
like this bro I feel like that's
outdated that doesn't hit hard Valley
because like the way that I talk about
like rural Southerners whatever mhm I
paint it with a broad brush but like the
valley girl it we don't feel offended
cuz we we don't even know people like
that really you know what I mean I do I
kind of see people like that I it's not
offensive in the same way yeah it's more
just funny us but I mean people from the
South probably think the same about
their Regional dialects I mean I grew up
in the San Fernando Valley which is
where the valley girl thing came from
and I definitely knew a lot of girls
that
talk but I'm saying it's not as broad as
of brush okay yeah that's more specific
to like La thing how about this hello do
you have an avocado toast there you go
yeah for
$35 oh it's only 35 that's a great deal
no cash may I is this is this avocado
ethically
sourced dumb ass is this coffee fair
trade oh no you'll have to take that
back
please let the chef know this is
unacceptable you know my daughter is
straight I'm trying to turn her trans
though it's way
cooler I want her to be hip in school
therefore I want her to be transgender I
yeah
exactly that's pretty good right I'm
trying yeah
yeah my do I went to a PTA meeting
and I noticed there wasn't a kitty
litter box in my child's
classroom I complained to this city
council and now there's a kitty box in
all classrooms so that kitty girls have
a gender specific place to go to the
bathroom got to think about those
FES I don't know what's the voice
because I don't like the valley one yeah
well um well now because the the valley
girl thing is kind of talking like this
yeah you're right that I feel like the
new thing is the um is like the vocal
fry thing I feel like they go they go
together kind of talking it's really
good talking like this where you just
kind of like don't seem interest I think
it's the same the valley girl and the
vocal it's the evolution of the valley
girl I guess Red Scare podcast my dad b
car I got a new mer doesn't hit as hard
as the kitty box stuff for me yeah can I
a Skinny Girl
Margarita that's good hi I went to the
mall the other
day and somebody started shooting people
and then I realized nobody had a gun to
Pro to protect us and we just ran I wish
I had a handgun on me what an idiot I am
for supporting gun legislation wow wow
do I have egg on my face now that's
right I wish we had oh this is good I
love I my favorite place to shop is
aroan their new smoothies are only $20
what a deal I very much I very much
don't go ahead sorry the playing the ELA
MA saying everyone and it's sounding
exactly like aroan is it gets
me oh yeah it sounds like he's saying
Aran how'd you figure that out that's
crazy someone said it I think it was Dan
I made that observation a while ago wild
yeah uh
yeah I'm trying to pick up some uh
advice in the damn chat but there it is
please
d darar liberas d
liberals I tell you what see that now
I'm my mixing the
characters see that's why we don't do
the LA one it's boring cuz we just are
that I'm trying we're already that let's
go back to the other one I'm trying to
equal things out yeah we triy is there
salt in this no no no no take it
back I said no salt no
seasoning you look like the kid from the
Vine with the with the
[Music]
hood that is very interesting
uh I ordered this food an hour
ago yeah somebody here this is a good
observation honestly calling Montana and
Ohio the south is a parody of
Californians and of itself I'm kidding I
know it's not in the South
[Music]
stop but they kind of have a point that
that that does
seem like so then my character of myself
what's y'all problems then apparently
I'm doing parody of my damn
self come on we're in good shape here I
won't see what all the fuss is
[Laughter]
about all right don't be mad at me
Southerners we love you I don't think
people were really mad but I was just
you know man people out here we serve
the people that's
it that's it that's all I do that's it I
live for the people like Jay Shetty
wishes he
was I'm what Jay Shetty wishes he was
that's a good one for like California I
very much enjoy the J shett podcast
right have you heard of Jay shett no
that's Global that's Global that's not
that's just Califor my friend in yoga
class let me know about a nice young man
named Jay shett mhm that's good he has a
wonderful podcast I like listening to
podcasts just listening to podcast is
kind of that's California coded uh sorry
I don't I don't I only drive in electric
vehicles I'm going to start I can't get
in the car in good
conscience
I'm doing it from my iPhone mic starting
a
podcast it's going to be a killer bro
everyone starting podcast in like my
barber literally asked me that's a good
one well I'm not even Ming but my barber
literally was like y I'm starting this
podcast that is a good one I have these
friends everybody does have a podcast
it's
wild that's a that that's a good La one
yeah anyone got a vape I uh my uncle is
a producer I'm trying to get an audition
meanwhile I'll work on my
podcast it's about healthy living and
spirituality but he was super
hot all right I don't know what do you
want from me okay before we go there's
some breaking news
okay check this out news this is very
funny uhoh oh more magazine oh no
did they post the James Charles one no
shot they did yo they posted it dude
they went
feral Goblin mode I literally turned to
El was like We'll never see that well
you don't don't uh
don't I said kids I think just like
oh my God sure okay and that's that's
they were shocked too when um like
whatever man pretty out of
that's a straight up the mic is
slam is
[Music]
um uh do uh just date people that are
over the legal image yeah do that be
appropriate do they include the James
Charles thing have you guys seen James
Charles this evening oh they did it oh
okay look they even put a
disclaimer yo People
magazine yes what the hellu legend
dude people are
legit legit we love people I'm a man of
the people of the people you just said
and you were right true okay wait this
is Iconic I got to see this on Tik Tok
dude people is blowing up yeah people's
the most reputable news Source cover win
that's what people say wow that's what
I've heard yeah yeah that's what I've
seen frankly it's what I've seen the
fact they added that disclaimer is
honestly pretty wild like I didn't even
say I just said have you guys seen James
Charles they're like we got to inform
the people and I love
people love
people yeah that's crazy they posted
that that's a dub for people that's a
dub for people everywhere love people I
did someone said in the comments did
Ethan say don't kids and then did
you see James Charles this evening yes
people they they really bleeped the
out of that people people people okay
People magazine I see you guys
love them stupid people uh I think AB
just obviously we moved Way Beyond that
but was this the Tweet you were thinking
about earlier I think AB dug it
up it done it didn't have 50,000 uh no
but this one it serves a good purpose
anyway yeah such a let down he say
Oliver Anthony said what we are the
Melting Pot of the world and that's what
makes us strong our diversity despite
that being like historically true
such a letdown did he sell out already
to the Richmond north of Richmond wow
want to sell out that was fast but
yeah I mean listen
I there was no winning for him from the
beginning he was going to be
cannibalized from the beginning yeah
yeah sorry that he's not racist I hope
you'll be okay yeah but I like it
obviously I like that he came out and
said it and I uh support him I'm just
confused a little bit
about like I said I mean it's just
sometimes
people if you're if you're 5 foot tall
and 500 lb then you and you look like a
Twinkie I'm going to roll you down the
street we got folks in the street ain't
got to heat and the be milk W listen I'm
I'm if you're
300b I don't like how good Wild he's a
great singer and and it's specifically
like there's a break and it's beautiful
on that line I wish he was saying
something it's just such a wild line and
was so out of place it's so crazy and I
love that earlier that whole statement
that we read that where he had somewhat
of a somewhat of a nuanced insightful
like his way of explaining it and then
yeah when you listen to it again it's
just like no that's he tried he tried he
that's not what you said listen I'm a
man of the people I I want social safety
nets I want these people to have food
you know what I mean I want want these
people to have health care I'm I'm in
favor of raising taxes on people like me
all right and I always vote for it when
it comes to it in California there's
always things to raise taxes I always
vote Yes there you go just class Trader
the good kind of class Trader so you
know I'm I'm one of
y'all one of y'all just
better I'm one of y'all just a little
better cuz La we got a Sheen to
us special kind of coating there's
there's a Coating in La all right tell
you what man we just got a nice coat
gold we gilded out here California a
codak
Grime all
right I love y'all what can I tell you
listen if Oliver wants a Redemption just
make re do another like men of the
People song
and just take out the fat lines I guess
and the welfare stuff but he says I want
people I people don't have food but then
he criticizes welfare like it makes no
sense that's how these people that's how
poor people get food food stamps damn
and I'm in favor of
that fat or skinny they all need to eat
all different sizes all different
flavors they all need to eat damn it you
know what I me all different
flavors all right thank you guys sorry
for letting everybody down you didn't
let us down I just want to say uh thanks
if we're going out I just want to say
thank you for a wonderful 5 years and uh
thank you for the gift and um so many
many more thank you Z thank you thank
you dude thank you brother can we go out
on five years by David Bowie definitely
uh claimed great song though amazing
song amazing you can pick a song to go
out but not that one
uh there it
is a greato
my my favorite I want toink on
myin faor coin yeah you see
this the Dono Dereck runs oh did I send
it the wrong chat sorry there you go can
we can we point out that fudge rounds
come in a box not a bag there it is
who's out of touch now who's out of
touch all who the is out of touch
now nice cat industry plant uh proof
thank you Derek runs a man of the people
mhm all right guys uh see members
tomorrow for our members only
episode and uh everybody else everybody
see you on Wednesday for another Jam
pack the action pack the week of shows
everybody see you next
time my girlfriend says thank you for
all the new girlfriends yeah think going
get all time high it's really high when
you keep getting higher D you're my
favorite on you turn my wallet into a p
think my favorite going to the moon
going
Theon